there's no time
[Music]
the time is 13. o'clock
[Music]
hey everybody what's going on it's
Wednesday night the only chat that I see
is sex bots get them out of sex spots
inside the damn chat room early first
thing to have I know right well they
really was here too selling their [ __ ]
services
I'm going to the thought no yeah they're
people piling in
there's that just showing up Zach go
ahead and kick the sex boy yeah he's
doing him he's kicking the sex bots out
all right Zach says hey there [ __ ]
I'm still sick as a dog I'm sorry to
hear that yeah he's been sick for a
couple days yeah might take tomorrow off
work too though I really don't want to
well I mean do what you got to do don't
don't let go to work and give other
people your cooties too so there's that
to keep yeah I've been feeling funny the
past two days but I don't know if it's
the [ __ ] that I'm on or if it's uh or if
it was a virus I think it might be a
mixture of of them both I think you got
cooties from the biker bar no I don't
know what it is even though you blamed
it on me I gotta do something blame it
on her you know but uh I heard you know
it was my understanding that you were
just [ __ ] Invincible when you're on
Trend so
and Trent gives you cough it's called
Trend cough and then
on my nose was a little bit sore and it
was stuffed up then it went away and it
was just I got a little bit of a cough
but it's just
I don't know if it was Chad or if it was
a virus
but I'd always heard that when you're on
trend
you're just impervious because you're
you're your system is so [ __ ]
filled with that [ __ ] you're so
aggressive just heal up apparently
you're not completely impervious it just
[ __ ] kills everything you know but uh
we'll see no I'm feeling a lot better
now
last night I was having a problem
breathing through my nose but it's yeah
I heard yeah I was coughing a lot yeah
but I don't know what it was we'll see
I'm not coughing now Danny Rowling said
Tom's a trendsetter
don't do that [ __ ] man
[ __ ] Trend was not worth it yeah he
did his last injection today we're just
hoping it wears off soon because yeah
probably it'll be at half strength in
about three days and six days it'll be
out of the system more or less yeah Zach
said there's a new respiratory bug going
around well I know that everybody's
getting well I could caught it and
hopefully whipped its ass
which took me about two days
three days something like that yeah I
feel a lot better now
so we'll see it's going to be a good uh
show tonight it's going to be a [ __ ]
paranormal show I know you guys like
those it's paranormal and True Crime all
in one at the same time which you know
that seems like I can't believe we
haven't done this topic before yeah
unless we did I'm pretty sure we have it
though no none of the when I started
doing the research I was like none of
this sounds familiar which that's a good
sign yeah
Isabella said I realized I have an old
digital copy of the Night Flyer at and
that is in uh 16-9 so it's the in the
correct theatrical aspect ratio
of what the Night Flyer where'd you get
it I don't know she said she had a
digital copy of it so it's out there
somewhere like I said well because we
said it was made for theatrical release
yeah I mean you know theoretically there
should be that'd be a version of that
that'd make a good bootleg you could
probably make some money off that
yeah you probably will yeah yeah
like if Jenny did the right packaging
and everything for that [ __ ] [ __ ] it and
then we clandestinely sold that
[ __ ] well we can't do it now we
can't do it and set it out loud
it's just an idea probably wouldn't make
anything off of it bigger bootleg though
not famous enough you need a whole
promotional campaign to sell a lot of
those well yeah that's kind of true of
everything yeah that's kind of why it's
like so hard it's hard to make money uh
you know it's easier to make money in
some ways but it's harder in some ways
because there's so much competition like
because you need to pay a lot of money
for advertising to get your [ __ ] in
front of everybody yeah and let's see
Camp guy said I gotta get a sleep study
everyone says I snore terribly and stop
breathing I've heard of those CPAP
machines but this will be the first time
I've used one on my face
yeah Danny Rowling told you to take some
NyQuil
I think I might have some of that around
here I just I haven't got any I very
rarely use over-the-counter type
medicines I don't either I mean I I use
ibuprofen I use ibuprofen to keep from
getting hangovers but that's about it I
don't really have problems otherwise I
hardly ever get colds
so I think I have some old like
generic 7-Eleven cold medicine from like
five years ago that maybe has some stuff
left in there but
I don't I don't like I don't usually
need it you know what I mean so I don't
usually buy it other than Ibuprofen or
aspirin which like I said I usually just
take every now and then likes to keep
from getting hangovers but you know
um let's see slasher friend said one of
these days
you should watch and review the film at
Quicksilver Highway I've heard of that
but you know
I don't think I've ever seen it though
yeah Isabella said that the um the
version of the movie she has is from the
DVD
so
so I guess they did release a DVD of it
it's just
I mean you can buy it it's just you
can't stream it anywhere that's the
problem that we had you know I mean
because obviously we didn't have time to
buy it I can't believe all that ice
melted already yeah I know it's like not
even hot in here really well the The Ice
was kind of like half melted chunks when
we started it's in there making ice I
added water to it okay
added water to it and everything's good
and we'll have ice in a bit oh okay so
we used all the ice so we don't have any
ice first there's no ice in there oh
okay so we gotta use all of it but you
know how it's got the whole hole in the
center yeah the hole gets bigger and
bigger as it melts yeah that's true and
it was all in one big Clump I had to
down break it apart and I used the whole
trade on those on those two glasses and
look it melted it's like yeah yeah look
at this shade it's like that yeah this
has been like literally been sitting
here for like five or seven yeah that's
about it
Sarah says finally get to enjoy a stream
at home I'm always closing the store
when y'all are on well that's good at
least you get to be at home yeah like I
said I'm kind of like I think this will
be kind of a fun topic it'll be a good
topic because you've got a lot of booze
too
yeah we went to the
we went to the liquor store today
actually we went to the liquor store
that's down by yeah Publix and we
determined that they had even more
flavors of that Old Smoky Moonshine yeah
than ABC Liquors have yeah had Mexican
girl working behind the counter she had
the pickles she says I like the pickle
one she was drinking yeah cause there's
one it's not it's like not a drink
technically but it's moonshine with
Pickles in it so it's pickle juice like
in pickle juice yeah she said it was
really good and then they had maraschino
cherries
they had
um
banana pudding but you can have that she
doesn't like that but I [ __ ] love
banana pudding they had strawberries and
cream yeah which I think I'll I think I
might have to try that one out those two
the banana pudding the strawberries and
cream moonshine are uh kind of gonna be
like Bailey's they're gonna be like
dessert drinks really yeah you're just
gonna have to like drink it in a little
bit yeah laugh like that it's gonna
drink a whole [ __ ] drink of it did
they come in a jar just like that it's
about 20 bucks yeah I think the Jar's 20
bucks but that's what it was that um
that ABC tail yeah I think it was well
it was 18.99 but it was on sale at ABC
so it actually might be more ABC when
it's not on sale and maraschino cherries
the other one had green olives in it
they had peaches peaches yeah but they
had they didn't have the butter pecan
but they did have um some other flavors
that ABC didn't have like I said they
had the banana pudding and the
strawberry cream they had apple pie yeah
my sister I told you my sister told me
that she thought that there was a like a
mocha coffee one or like a coffee and
chocolate one that it was the same brand
but they didn't have that one either
unless it's a different brand was
thinking of but she was pretty sure it
was old smokey headley's asking so does
it just taste like flavored vodka
um not really
it kind of I don't know it had it's like
it has a different kind of thing to it
yeah it depends on which flavors you get
and the ones that are based in cream I
would probably put them up with Bailey's
Irish Cream kind of like that I mean
that's what the butter pecan tastes like
to make except if they taste exactly as
described like that tasted just like
butter pecan ice cream melted yeah and
it was alcoholic but boozy yeah uh
moonshine doesn't really have a flavor
it's like a real so kind of like vodka
yeah kind of like vodka
it's in between vodka and Everclear if
you've ever had Everclear which is damn
near pure sugar cane alcohol
or or grain alcohol uh you can run a
alcohol burning car off of it it's dry
super dry and not
not real pleasant but
what you could do back in the day is you
Ever Clear when I was a kid in the 80s
came in a metal can like Hawaiian Punch
can yeah I remember yeah it came like
that
and that can you could
pop two holes in it with a can opener
those two triangle holes that you make
and
um
Spike
two or three huge punch bowls and you
just put a bunch of dab
Hawaiian punch in a bowl with ice big
old [ __ ] bow and one third of that
can would spike that whole [ __ ] punch
bowl
I mean you could literally get 20 people
loaded on on that one
yeah it'd be like a whole night of bad
decisions yeah yeah and it was cheap
and it was [ __ ] real [ __ ] Southern
redneck [ __ ] man [ __ ] drinking
Everclear
uh it was not high brow it was
[ __ ] very high value okay you got a
lot for your money
it didn't taste good you can't drink
that straight
you can but it's not pleasant
but it it's good it mixed in [ __ ] that's
real sweet and fruity and it was good at
that
that's all we drank it in Hawaiian Punch
Sarah said I've had homemade moonshine
moonshine with the cherries it was
horrible and I don't remember what
happened most of that night
yeah I've been there uh Greg Probert
said does anyone here listen to The
Uncanny podcast very good podcast from
the BBC concerning ghosts and
Poltergeist I don't think I've heard of
that but I don't think I've ever
listened to it but that actually sounds
really good maybe we should get into
that it's just like there's so many
because somebody told me about like an
HP Lovecraft podcast that sounded like
really really good and I was like man I
really need to get into that but [ __ ]
man I just I have so much stuff I want
to listen to I've said before like my
YouTube to watch list is like [ __ ]
several days long because every time
because they keep like recommending new
[ __ ] and I'm like oh that sounds good
ooh that sounds good and like I keep
putting the watch later and I just never
have to have to watch it
um Camp guy said I've seen an Old Timer
put regular round hard peppermint
candies into a jar of clear liquor clear
like it must be a time I'd ever clear
that might be good probably all right I
mean I like peppermint anything pretty
much you could you wouldn't have to use
the peppermint candy
you could use it why wouldn't you
because peppermint is good you could use
peppermint peppermint extract extract
would be a way to go with sugar that
would be the same thing and it'd be a
lot more efficient but that's probably
just what he had
you know if
back in the depending on where he was
from back in the old days you know
getting peppermint extract might be
might well no they always had that
because they were making [ __ ] cakes
and candies out of it yeah it was around
it's just probably a lot cheaper and to
get your hands on the [ __ ] peppermint
candies they weren't worth anything yeah
it was saying about Jolly Ranchers yeah
I kind of feel like that was more the
thing that kids were doing when I was in
high school like putting Jolly Ranchers
in the [ __ ] yeah like of different
flavors Zach said most drunk I've ever
been was off honey flavored Jack Daniels
and it was also maybe the most
disgusting thing I've ever tasted man
you [ __ ] high man [ __ ] hunting I
like the Honey Jack Daniels I I actually
like it yeah it was good I like that so
was the cinnamon
wasn't it cinnamon yeah apple yeah the
Apple that was the last one yeah yeah
the Apple one's good
and there's another it's not Jack
Daniels what's the other one Jim Beam
yeah the Apple gym beam is pretty good
too I don't really I don't like Cinema I
like cinnamon like I like actual
cinnamon like I love cinnamon toast and
cinnamon buns and [ __ ] like that but
anything any like cinnamon candy or
cinnamon booze like Fireball and stuff
like that I don't like it it's just like
I said it gives me instant [ __ ]
heartburn so I can't really and I don't
like Red Hots or Hot Tamales or like any
of those kind of like cinnamon candies
I'm just not into it but I like cinnamon
as a concept I would you know I even
sprinkle cinnamon in my coffee and [ __ ]
like that because I really like it but I
don't like cinnamon flavored things
uh Trey said I had a bad run-in with
peach schnapps in 1991. yeah
and Danny we're only talking about
Goldschlager yeah like Tom likes
Goldschlager I don't really like it
though yeah I don't really like it like
I said it's not so much that I don't
like it it's just it just burns and then
it's like and then I'm like oh you know
what I mean like it gives me really
really bad heartburn like immediately
uh Zach says uh no don't break a
peppermint you're making me want to get
more mint moose tracks ooh that sounds
good
honestly it's Christmas time one of the
best things about Christmas time is you
can get peppermint candy ice cream which
is one of my favorite flavors probably
like mint chocolate chip is my favorite
flavor but peppermint candy is good too
and you can maybe you can get it all
year now but I think when I was a kid
like that's one of my favorite flavors
and you can only get it around Christmas
time so I was always kind of like
I thought it was like a jip because I
wanted it the rest of the time
all right so
do we have anything else we need to
cover before I get into the ghosts and
murders and stuff like that
oh there's still everybody's still
talking about booze
yeah Zach said cinnamon candy and booze
is spicy but not in the right way
yeah that's what I mean it's just kind
of like I don't know I don't know what
it is and then Trey said oh man I love
mint chocolate chip ice cream I do too I
mean lots of kind of ice cream are good
but that's probably my favorite flavor
if you made me pick one
Janet said my worst night drinking was
orange vodka
that doesn't sound good
you can mix it with other things well
you can mix orange vodka with orange
juice you can mix it with you can mix it
with anything that would go good with
orange flavor you know what I mean
I can't think of anything some might
even say because I know some people like
chocolate and orange together
so you could even mix it with like
chocolate vodka and chocolate chocolate
vodka and orange vodka yeah I mean I
don't really like orange and chocolate
together but I know a lot of people do
so that's a very Christmassy thing
especially in the UK you get those
[ __ ] what are those things called who
makes those like the orange it's like a
it's an actual size of an orange but
it's chocolate it's like chocolate but
it has orange flavor and then you like
and then I don't I don't think it's
Italian but like it's in foil and you
like hit it like that and then it breaks
apart yeah I thought I think it is
Italian it might be I don't know but
they sell I mean it's hugely popular
right yeah
especially around Christmas time or at
least it was when I was there
Trey says uh I really don't drink much
anymore since I hit 50 in 2020 it just
takes too much out of me the next day
yeah I feel that it's just inject test
well the thing about it too is that yeah
I mean well once you get older like
whether you inject anything or not I
mean eventually it's going to catch up
it does take longer to recover yeah
um you know if you drink a lot or if
you're out really late or something like
that Terry's that's it that's what I was
thinking of
the orange yeah as you get older your
your endocrine system has slowed down
your ability to recover is
not what it was when you were younger
if you do hormone replacement you get a
lot of that back
it's the same like when your teeth fall
out you won't be able to chew meat you
put false teeth in you can shoot
same thing
just my personal experience and it's not
just me other dudes that do it you feel
and you'll finally get some good sleep
and you'll feel better your women won't
be able to keep up with you but that's
just how it is
you're not gonna say anything about that
no she's not gonna say anything about it
okay I don't want to talk about
testosterone okay all right
gotta do it we're supposed to be doing a
ghost show we're doing it
that's all it is
metabolism
Trey says I can do the late nights but
add alcohol and I'm useless yeah I mean
to be honest
um I've started like even when we do go
out I've started drinking less like when
we go to um Memento Mori or something
like that I'll just have like one or two
of those like [ __ ] like gin and
tonics in a can like early on in the
evening and then I'll just drink water
the rest of the night and usually I'm
okay you know what I mean
Mrs Evans already party said yes ghosts
like I said ghosts and murderers
on the same show
which I don't know why we haven't done
this before because I let I'm always
kind of looking for that sweet spot of
like true crime stories but that also
have a paranormal angle to them that's
why I so much liked that what was that
creepy ass [ __ ] that killed all
those dudes and like buried him on his
Fox Hollow Farm or whatever the hell
that was yeah that's why I like that
because it was like a cereal yeah yeah
yeah yeah because it was like a serial
killer and also a ghost story because it
was supposed to be like no herb herb no
herb herb the perv and like I said I'm
kind of surprised that he's not one of
the better known serial killers because
that is one [ __ ] up story like that
kind of [ __ ] yeah he had an indoor pool
with a whole bunch of mannequins all
dressed up in like little Club attire
and [ __ ] around see that's weird it's
like that seems like a detail that would
stick in people's minds because people
love like weird [ __ ] like that I love
weird [ __ ] like that I pick up these gay
boys and [ __ ] take them back there
and [ __ ] you know whine and die in
them and
get high with them and why they weren't
looking and he'd choke them out
suffocate them
it's weird [ __ ] it is yeah it might have
had there might have been some kind of a
rod of asphyxia thing going on and then
he'd overdo it and kill him
I think he was playing with him and they
were in on it for a while
and then he just do it until they were
dead
he was a perv man yeah a millionaire
was it Dollar Store
or uh no it wasn't one that it wasn't
one that we have around here like it was
a Dollar General or anything what was
the name of that but it's called dollar
something yeah I can't remember what it
was Dollar General or dollar or tree no
it wasn't that no it wasn't one of the
ones you know it wasn't one of those but
it was called dollar yeah it was dollar
something but it wasn't one of the most
famous ones right Jeffy art said
probably it's because uh herb wasn't
officially convicted of the crime see
that's right right because didn't he die
like kill himself yeah went on the run
and killed himself so I guess that's why
because he never
so they never had a big trial right
I guess so so he didn't really make the
big time
I remember the news report so they
showed his car on the side of the road
and him in it yeah I remember that you
could see his outline of his head
sideways like that you couldn't really
see detail but he was in the front
passenger see what he bloated blew his
head off with a pistol
if I remember correctly I mean you know
I guess he saved everybody some uh some
money yeah kicked his wife out of the
house because he was married
yeah had kids and everything
some of them do yeah
see that's what's scary everybody he was
up in that closet Zach you never know
yeah
that they can act normal we'll look at
[ __ ] BTK they didn't know he was a
[ __ ] serial killer all that time
right
[ __ ] have wife and kids and he seemed
totally normal yeah
that's that's scarier to me than
anything yeah but no I mean here's the
thing man if I can I'm sorry [ __ ]
[ __ ] Raider
Raider wasn't normal to me even when he
was walking around normal I would have
thought that that dude was a dick well
yeah but I mean to an extent like being
a dick is kind of normal
he just came across as just a functional
worker but that he had a stick up his
ass
yeah he did a lot of but I've got some
people like that yeah I mean lots of
people like that so I wouldn't have
thought anything was unusual like I said
I've never met him like I might have if
I'd have met him like maybe I'd been
like whoa that's a serial killer right
he would have killed you well probably
yeah he'd have killed you you'd have
been his type you think yeah
he liked you gross yeah
and he and you know it wouldn't probably
wouldn't have been anything I could do
to protect you because he would make
sure that I wasn't around when it
happened
well yeah that was the whole thing he
was sneaky [ __ ] yeah he'd sneak it
dude
so you know as much as I make fun of
Dennis Dennis was [ __ ] dangerous
yeah very dangerous because he he had
the intelligence that you needed and the
excuses that you needed to get on your
property and get up in your [ __ ] and
[ __ ] uh get towards your one get to
your woman while you weren't around all
right and and I [ __ ] stupid some you
know that might sound sexist and [ __ ]
but no you have to understand something
Dennis Raider is probably six to eight
times stronger physically than Jenny
he'd run right through Jenny she she
wouldn't be able to resist and he used
force all right these dudes come up they
[ __ ] built a woman right in the
[ __ ] head man wow they're not being
gentlemen about it you know they're used
strength and then they start talking and
talk you into things here I'm just gonna
tie you up it's gonna be all right
everything's gonna be over and then
they're gonna [ __ ] use you up for a
couple hours and oh by the way uh now I
gotta kill you here you want some water
here dry your eyes it's okay I just
can't let you live and then kill you
you know [ __ ] Maniac it's Savages
you know
that [ __ ] is still alive too isn't he
yeah
I'd [ __ ] him up though
he's probably in bad shape right now
I hope so Jay's probably real bad I hope
he's suffering they don't get much they
don't get much physical exercise you
know
when they're locked up like that
so he's probably atrophied quite a bit
he's probably just a
Doughboy
he wasn't in real great shape when he
was around he's also older so
that's true yeah he's not the man he was
well I mean like I said I kind of hope
he has like some really really painful
diseases too
ass cancer yeah
among other things yeah but you can
laugh at those dudes you have to look at
them from the point of view of the
average woman the average woman they're
stronger than the average woman woman by
several times as dumpy as they looked
there's still just a lot more muscle
mass on them
but they weigh more
longer arms and [ __ ] so they just and
evil you know
they'll have all that [ __ ] planned out
two or three two or three steps ahead so
a woman can't really out think him but
he forces a woman down into a basically
a little trap shoot that he's already
pre-planned
because they kind of have it down to his
sides
well the thing is they have an advantage
because they are particularly with BTK I
mean he had been watching them for weeks
and weeks yeah so and like the women I
think didn't know so it's like to them
it's kind of like who the [ __ ] is this
dude like showing up all of a sudden but
he's been like watching you for watching
it's all pre-planned and everything's
timed properly and everything so it's
it's a trap
and he's gonna use a bunch of ruses and
lies [ __ ]
yeah so very dangerous
this is Evan's Arty party said ladies
get a gun and let those creeps [ __ ]
around and find out yeah
but you also want to get training and
you want to get a [ __ ] concealed
weapon permit
I just do not Advocate ever letting a
guard down
especially if there is anybody out if
you're in an area where there you don't
have guys around you who care about you
be it family members or whatever
you kind of want to be packing you know
and always have something handy
because they they're ambushed Predators
they come up out of nowhere they don't
give you any [ __ ] time you know it's
not like hold on I'll be back in a
second I go to get my gun that's not
gonna [ __ ] work
but um especially when you're up in the
house make sure that
if somebody comes in there's you have a
few minutes of warning something that'll
wake you up some kind of alarm
arm yourself don't go investigate just
[ __ ] go into a corner level off that
[ __ ] rifle at the [ __ ] doorway and
just wait for that sucker to walk in and
blast him don't go looking for him let
him make him come well I mean learn from
horror movies if you hear something
downstairs that sounds like somebody
broke in
assume that somebody did so don't go
down there and check hello likes don't
do that yeah don't do that now I can I
got [ __ ] close combat close quarter
combat training and [ __ ] I'm x Hunter
first Evermore division infantry and
[ __ ] so no I'll go down there and
[ __ ] room clear all right I got the
equipment for the skills
but no an untrained woman no just hide
up in a corner and [ __ ] level that
[ __ ] right at the doorway in Ambush and
when he [ __ ] walks in don't even
hesitate just open fire
and don't do one shot just shoot that
[ __ ] dry
yeah pretend it's like a zombie that's
right you gotta at least double tap yeah
just [ __ ] rapid fire like I said
you've seen horror movies they always
get up yeah don't just make sure that
that doesn't happen
but all the successful defenses always
were like that even the little 12 year
old kid who hid in the closet with that
revolver when that burglar opened up
that [ __ ] closet door you let him
have it like three rounds right in a
chest he was 12.
killed him deader than [ __ ] and [ __ ] is
very dead that's why it came out of you
ew yeah
[Laughter]
and some people were like wait he was
just burglarized in the house yeah but
you're a [ __ ] 12 year old boy in the
[ __ ] house and dude broke in I mean
you don't know we leave the house no
you're just gonna [ __ ] blast him
yeah I don't blame that game yeah
[ __ ] no charges filed of course
you're [ __ ] 12. okay
and like I said you don't know what that
cops are like good job yeah cops like
good job yeah you don't know what that
dude's playing you know what that dude's
doing that's what I mean I don't know
what his intentions are
you're in here so obviously you have bad
intentions he's at fault so he's in a
he's [ __ ] broken into kind of on you
isn't it yeah it's on him
slasher friend said in the original The
Vanishing uh the villain is also a
family man yes that's right oh man I
need to like review that movie that may
be so good
um the 1990 romantic film ghost is also
about a ghost who solves his own murder
that's right that's right we're not
gonna talk about that though we're going
to talk about some well we're gonna talk
about some allegedly real cases I have
three because these are these are kind
of like
the famous ones I guess these are the
ones that kind of always come up
but I hadn't actually one of these
stories I'd heard because it was on
Unsolved Mysteries a long time ago and I
kind of vaguely remembered it from that
but the other two I had I didn't know
much about prior so but I thought they
were like really really interesting all
of them
yeah Mrs Evans already party said he
won't be a repeat offender no yeah [ __ ]
that dude that's what I mean it's like
so
I don't there's really no reason for him
to be in there so
no you break into a house No One's Gonna
feel bad
hey you got killed
you just gotta assume the worst Zach
said I legit wonder if old herb hung out
at the gay bar I hung out in
Indianapolis
possibly
I mean yeah and Camp guy said he
probably did there were only a few very
few gay bars back then
they did mention the name of the bar in
one of the documentaries I saw on
YouTube yeah I think they did mention
one of the bars but I can't remember the
name of it because it was such a long
time ago so it's possible
yeah like I said in a city like
Indianapolis back then there wouldn't
have been that many gay bars so I'm
assuming that he probably went to
the main one oh her
B herb
herb increase you know it's hard to
understand what happened to all herb I
know we're off topic but this is this
does have is Herb in this uh episode
because this is a paranormal [ __ ] okay
no this is this is ghosts there it's all
the like victims that solved yeah that's
what this is about I don't know what
happened to her
did he go crazy because he was losing
his business or or what because he was
kind of losing control over that
business or was he losing his business
because he was going crazy
you know
yeah see that's the thing you don't know
what's happening
what caused what these dudes need to
learn how to handle their [ __ ] better
yeah because look like bad [ __ ] happens
to everybody people lose jobs like you
know uh you know your wife her husband
or whatever leaves you it's like you
gotta like suck it up and like learn to
deal with [ __ ] you can't like fall apart
and turn into a serial killer or like go
around blowing people away okay you just
can't do that it makes you [ __ ] deal
with your [ __ ] makes you wonder if
he's losing his business so he goes
crazy and he starts killing these gay
dudes during these [ __ ] wild sex
[ __ ] parties or whatever
or
is he so so much getting off into this
killing these dudes of these wild sex
Potters that he's neglecting his
business which one is happening I would
imagine that I'm probably leaning toward
the second thing
that he's so much into these dudes that
he's [ __ ] letting the business fall
apart yeah because to me it seems like
the more because it's very much in a
Serial Killer's kind of um
pathology
that they'll start out doing kind of
like little [ __ ] and if they get away
with that then they'll keep like upping
the ante so I kind of feel like what
dudes like that do it's like well I'll
just do this little bitty thing like
sometimes they start out killing animals
or just like hurting people or doing
things like that but then like they
start getting more and more bold and
maybe that's what he was doing like
maybe he was kind of getting into
situations with other guys and like
sometimes it was like consensual to an
extent and then he was taking things a
little bit farther and a little bit
farther and then like as it was going on
he was getting more and more obsessed
with it and then he was just like oh I
have to just keep like I said like
upping the ante and then he was just
like didn't even care about work anymore
I kind of feel like that's I don't know
I wasn't there but that's to me seems
more consistent with like
um with their kind of psychology you
know I was kind of thinking it was the
opposite well maybe it could have been I
was kind of thinking thinking that he
was losing his business
and it was kind of like the end of the
world was happening he gets rid of the
wife
so he just goes down in the damn sexual
orgy of murder he's like [ __ ] it I'm
gonna lose all this [ __ ] anyway so I'm
gonna go out with a bang and uh I'm
gonna do anything everything I want with
these dudes and it doesn't really matter
if I kill them I'm getting off on
killing them because I'm gonna kill
myself anyway because I I can't live
like a poor person I think my my I'm
losing everything anyway might have been
that like an apocalyptic thinking
Navy Jeff yard said I think according to
your previous podcast herb was already
institutionalized prior to his killings
okay oh yeah I had forgotten about that
yeah like I said it's been a while it's
been a while since we did that
Danny Rowling said like the guy in San
Diego who lost his parents and wife then
stole a tank and went on a rampage in
California
I think that happens too like I said
learn to [ __ ] deal with your [ __ ]
though tank boy was cool though I like
tank boy
he was a nutcase he was a [ __ ]
nutcase he's gonna ran over all those
[ __ ] cars in [ __ ] L.A with that
tank with MC he had an M60 main battle
tank
he was an ex-tager and he knew that
those things don't have keys he just
walked into the [ __ ] plate he walked
in knew he knew where and how [ __ ]
tanks are stored on [ __ ] post I think
he was wearing a uniform so he he could
fake it
just walked in
you know he [ __ ] had all the train
and jumped in a fuel attack and [ __ ]
took off in it
ran down the [ __ ] Street running over
[ __ ] cars
cops killed him though eventually
they got in through the turret I think
if I remember correctly they got in
there and got him
I thought no he killed himself that's it
no I think are we talking about a
different guy
he got stuck on a medium
aren't we talking about the guy that
they made that documentary dread about
no this dude stole a real oh okay stole
a real M60 battle oh okay I was I was
thinking about that guy the tread guy no
and he was running over he'd run over
the whole rows of parked cars and run
over like oh yeah yeah cars that's right
and then he ended up on the freeway
that's right and he tried to go from
uh he tried to go into the oncoming
traffic and he got caught on the
concrete
median that's what that's what happened
to him
and the Treads lost contact with the
ground
and there the cops got on top on top of
the tank and eventually they got him
I think he I think they killed him
though they shot him I think
when it got in through the hatch of the
turret somehow God I thought that I
didn't know that the driver's
compartment connected to the turret but
maybe it did in the M1 in the M1 Abrams
I don't think it it does connect I think
the driver's position is totally
separate from the rest of the crew I
think
I don't think that you could get a shot
in there it's been a long time since
I've been inside an M1 but it's been a
long time
and that's not a detail I remember I
have to go back and look I think it's a
totally separate compartment
Danny Rowling said that guy looked up to
Timothy McVeigh uh also one shot to the
shoulder and succumbed to his injury
that's okay
yeah Danny Rowling said there was
another guy who went on a spree with a
modified bulldozer that's who I was
thinking of the one that they made the
documentary tread about yeah it's a real
good documentary it is a good
documentary I think it might be on to be
actually like for free or it was like
good yeah dude made his own tank toward
it toward a damn town down but he killed
himself yeah he killed himself yeah
um all right so let's uh you want to get
on to the one onto the ghosts and stuff
like I said we're doing three I was
gonna do four but I thought well I know
how [ __ ] goes and we've already been on
for 40 minutes and we haven't even
gotten into the [ __ ] so you know so I'm
glad we only did three but you know I
think I think these are all good cases
although I have to say wait a minute
John Gore said speaking of wild gay sex
parties anyone here of mummification
parties it's pretty crazy
I never heard of that but now that you
say it I'm like oh of course I'm
actually surprised that they haven't we
got so many gays and leather daddies in
the [ __ ] chat [ __ ] somebody knows
about it they're gonna [ __ ] jump in
there this [ __ ] it's interesting because
we just talked about Young Sherlock
Holmes the other day that has like a
mummification in there yeah but it's not
willing mummification like they're
mummifying people alive that uh
absolutely did not want to be mummified
I would imagine which actually kind of
horrified me when I was a kid but
get out of these damn
[ __ ] leather daddies and power
bottoms and bears and [ __ ] all kinds
of otters and [ __ ] and [ __ ] in the in
the chat
otters in the chat otters yeah
sure why not
Zach's probably a otter you think
probably
I don't know he's uh he stopped talking
so he stopped talking okay he's writing
down his [ __ ] about mummification he's
like okay I gotta check out yeah I'm on
vacation yeah remember this time we were
down to [ __ ] um Fire Island and
[ __ ] uh yeah we had a modification
party
Mama find each other and [ __ ] making
Jello
dreams breathing strong pouring Jello
put them in the refrigerator and then
they come out and then come out of the
jello
this was just some gay dudes to do
jello shot party
well straight people do that too yeah
no no
it's gonna be more [ __ ] crazy well I
know that more creative it's gonna have
better music
let's get a much better music
yeah Zach just has a little wink Emoji
Jeff yard said uh used to work at a
fetish shop in Wilton Manors they would
have a back room that hosted parties for
almost everything at least legally yeah
I believe it I believe it I mean like I
said mummification that's I'd never
heard of that specifically but now that
you say it I'm just kind of like oh yeah
well let's dance to reason I could I
could see you then I could see that in a
way it might be kind of cool if you go
like full on with the whole theme and
everything like going full on Egyptian
and you have like [ __ ] you know
sarcophagus there and [ __ ] like that'd
be that'd be pretty neat oh Dex Zach's
responding
I may as well be an otter and I don't
think mummification sounds fun I like
moving around too much
I think like being like restrained is
I'm not really into that either I don't
really I don't really like being
confined in one spot so much you know I
get that some people like that I'm not
judging I'm just saying I don't I don't
really like being
people forcing me into like one position
I don't like that yeah I'm
claustrophobic I don't like that [ __ ] I
mean I'm not claustrophobic necessarily
but I don't really like because I'm not
bothered by that but it's just like I
want to be able to like get up and walk
around if I need to so I don't I don't
like being I wouldn't like being like
tied up or bound or anything like that
because I know like some people are
really into s m yeah no thanks I don't
even like being in like tight clothes
honestly
I noticed that I don't like it I don't
like y'all need to be seeing some of
this [ __ ] that's been happening
Jenny's [ __ ]
she's getting in real good shape I'm
saying I was like I'm gonna have to get
you some sexy ass [ __ ] booty shorts
now and she's like giggling and [ __ ] and
says I'm gonna get you some of them
[ __ ] cat suits and stuff man [ __ ]
some
the [ __ ] kinky patterns on there
[ __ ] walking around with a booty like
that now she's [ __ ] on that [ __ ]
[ __ ]
doing that [ __ ] bicycle all the time
getting what they would call
an onion booty
onion booty or apple booty wanna do what
they would call it or what you would
call it oh yeah I'd call it that too
I've never I've heard I've heard the
Apple but I've never heard onion booties
I've never heard onions you made that up
no I did not okay no I did not it feels
up what you talking about yeah white
folks don't know what a damn onion booty
is yeah it's on your booty
I mean I'm not I'm not onion booty yeah
I just I just never heard that yeah yeah
I mean I know I know what it means yeah
it's pretty self-efficient it's a little
bit bigger than an apple
okay so there's a whole taxonomy as a
whole system
I thought that your uh area of expertise
was boobs that too bubology and
bootiology oh okay both oh so now you
have two peas exactly exactly
it was a Jesus it was a dual major
so I have to it's my job yeah
it's my job it's all I mean all the
ridiculous [ __ ] you said I have to kind
of like deflate that a little bit plus
it amuses me to deflate it
you know what I mean it's all fun and
game
yeah really it's like kind of like I
wonder if the ice is all
right go ahead and start it up so now
that we're 45 minutes in talking about
onion booties and everything like that
so we really have to get into the actual
topic you know what I mean this this is
why we don't have that many subscribers
because people like tune in being like
what the [ __ ] these two idiots are like
talking about some other [ __ ] that
doesn't have anything to do with the
topic at hand so I swear to God we're
gonna get it I don't know how long we're
gonna stay on the topic you guys know
how it goes okay so the first case I
want to talk about
is I feel like this is probably the most
famous one I mean this was one that has
like its own Wikipedia page and
everything
so this is the case of Zona heester shoe
uh best known better known as The
Greenbrier ghost
now this happened in the late 19th
century in West Virginia
so this woman was actually
um
supposedly murdered in 1897 and uh even
though it was kind of like seen as an
accident at first
what ended up happening
was that uh her mom
said that her ghost had come to her and
said what really happened and we'll see
what uh what transpired from that
situation
so it's January of 1897.
now there's a guy named Erasmus Edward
Shu I'm just going to call him Edward
because Erasmus is too much of a pain in
the ass to say uh he was a blacksmith in
Greenbrier County West Virginia
now he's out doing his blacksmithing or
whatever
and he sends this kid who was like a
neighbor boy who would like run errands
for them and stuff
and he says hey why don't you go back to
my house and see if my wife Zona Zona
Easter shoe
um they had been married for three
months by the way
she needs anything from the market you
know and go get it for her
so the boy's like all right so he goes
to the house
and walks into the house which was like
a little log cabin or whatever
and he finds Zona lying at the foot of
the stairs
so this kid is like looking at her and
being like at first he thought she was
just asleep because she was just laying
there and they said she was stretched
out like kind of straight like her legs
were together
um her head was kind of like tilted to
one side like one hand was on her chest
and like the other one was next to her
like she didn't look [ __ ] up or
anything like that
so the kid was like maybe she just fell
asleep at the bottom of the stairs
that's weird so he's like calling to her
like at you know try to wake her up so
she obviously didn't say anything so he
kind of freaked out and ran out the
house
so he told he went to his mom back to
his house and told his mom
um yeah I think Mrs shu is dead over
there so she got the local Doctor Who
was also the coroner which I guess was
the case in a lot of these kind of small
towns uh his name was George Knapp
now I guess he was busy so he didn't get
to the house for like an hour because he
was doing some other [ __ ]
now by the time that he got to the
shoe's house uh Edward Shu the husband
had already come home
he had picked up his wife Zona thank you
Mrs Evans already party yay you started
send us the money yeah
maybe that's what we should do we'll
just like get started we'll we'll keep
the topic for ransom until like seven
you know what I mean but yeah so uh all
right so
so the husband had already come home
he had picked up his wife Zona from the
floor
had taken her carried her up to their
bedroom
had washed her body
dressed her in clothes and laid her out
on the bed
and he even like prepared her body for
burial essentially like put her in um
her favorite dress which I think was
like burgundy and it had this real high
neck on it with the stiff collar and put
like a veil over her face
a little suspicious it's a little
suspicious I'm just saying
so uh Dr Knapp comes in and starts
examining the body
and while he's doing that the husband is
like crying the whole time like he's
really like you know having a hard time
and he's just like cradling her oh my
God she's dead blah blah he's like
really having her fit
but um so nap is like hey can I check
out like her head and neck and
everything and at that point Edward
becomes a little bit
um you know he's like oh no no like he
gets like all agitated
and at this point Doc's like well you
know you know he's having a hard time
his wife just died and he's really upset
um so I'll just like you know come back
later it's fine
so he left now the body that he like the
parts of the body that he would have
actually got to that he actually got to
examine he didn't really find anything
weird about it so
um you know and he'd actually been
because like I said he was the town
doctor and I guess he was like the only
one and he had actually been treating
Zona for a few weeks prior to her death
so he actually on the death certificate
he put the cause of death as I love this
Everlasting faint what
I'm not entirely sure what that means
what a great band name that would be
yeah Everlasting faint I like it I like
it it has a nice ring to it
that's what he put out first
but then later he changed it to
complications from pregnancy even though
as far as I know and I mean this was
like 1897 so I don't know but
um as far as I know like nobody was
really sure if she was pregnant or not
so I don't know if he was just grasping
at straws or whatever I mean
complications from a pregnancy she died
but Everlasting faint sounds a lot
better I don't even know I don't even
know what that means I mean I guess She
fainted and she's not waking up so it's
an everlasting faint I mean I guess it's
very descriptive it's not really a cause
or a reason but you know I I I can see
that all right yeah She fainted she's
not getting up yeah that's essentially
what that means
so uh so yeah so they took zona's body
back to her childhood uh home like her
hometown and they buried her
um at the funeral her husband was acting
real weird like a lot of people kind of
pointed out like he was like pacing back
and forth by the casket he kept like
farting around with the body like
especially around the head and neck kind
of area
uh he also covered her head and neck
with a scarf which didn't match the
dress
um and people were like bro what the
[ __ ] are you doing and she's like oh
well it was her favorite I know it
doesn't match but she would have wanted
to be buried in it also they said that
he propped her head up with a pillow and
then like a rolled up cloth
so
everyone like thought it was weird but
they were like well you know everybody
expresses grief in a different way so
maybe he's just maybe that's just the
way he expresses grief we're not really
sure ever like people did think it was
weird but nobody thought it was like
overtly suspicious you know what I mean
and this guy was I mean most people kind
of liked him like they thought he was an
okay dude and everything
so you know it was kind of like that
now the one person who absolutely did
not like this dude was zona's Mom Mary
Jane Easter uh she had never liked this
[ __ ] and even like even though
uh you know her daughter was buried and
everyone thought it was an accident like
she had just you know fainted or fallen
down the stairs or whatever the hell
um she was like I think that
[ __ ] killed her that's what I
think
so um she started at least as far as The
Story Goes
she started praying that Zona would come
to her come back from the dead and tell
her what really happens because she
really really wanted to know
and again so the story goes she prayed
every night for weeks and weeks until
finally her prayer was apparently
answered
Mary Jane said that her daughter came to
her in a dream
four nights in a row to tell her what
had happened
now how she described it later on and
she never wavered from this story like
from the from this time until the time
that she died
she said that her daughter appeared
first as a bright light
um and then would like took on a human
form and she said the whole room got
cold like when she like took on her
human form or whatever
Zona told her mom that uh Edward had
been really really violent and abusive
toward her
and one night he had come home and
um thought that she that he um that she
hadn't made him any meat for dinner
and he got like really upset about it
because obviously that's a thing that
you want to kill somebody over because
that's like a super big deal I suppose
anger issues you have them so yeah so he
got went into a rage and broke her neck
now the mom said that the ghost in her
dream
turned her head completely around like
to demonstrate that her negative which
to me I was like I read that and I was
like woo that'd be like super creepy
like even if it wasn't real or like a
good job that's super that'd be super
strong it's not like a damn horror movie
it is well yeah this does sound like a
heart yeah
so she turned her head completely around
like look mom he broke my neck it's like
that's like creepy did they ever make a
movie of this I wonder I don't think
they did
um so then the ghost like walks away but
with her head still like like that's
[ __ ] creepy it's creepy that's what
she said she's in her dream she said
it's in her dream yeah she didn't say
she saw it in real life she said she had
a dream
um yeah so she had a dream of that
so Mary Jane she has this dream several
nights in a row and she is so convinced
that this is really what happened that
she goes to the local prosecutor her
name is John Preston and she spends like
basically the whole day at this dude's
office like trying to get him to reopen
the case
now I don't know if this dude actually
believed in the ghost story or what but
she basically like stayed there until
she you know until she convinced him to
you know to kind of look into the [ __ ]
and the thing about it too is that I
don't think it was entirely just the
ghost story because he did like kind of
ask around and then he started hearing
all these stories about
um
Edward acting weird like at the funeral
and also like when they first found the
body like of him like carrying her up
the stairs and like putting her in the
dress and all that kind of stuff they're
like that's a little bit weird so he's
like okay well even if the ghost story
isn't real that is pretty strange so
maybe we should like look into that and
Dr Knapp too the guy that had done you
know kind of the the coroner like
examination he was like well you know I
was there and I didn't really get a good
chance to look out the neck or the head
because he was acting all crazy so my
examination wasn't as complete as it
maybe could have been so sure I mean we
should maybe reopen the case
so they decided
um Preston decides to do like a whole
autopsy or to like authorize a whole
autopsy
so a couple days after that
um Zora's body zona's body was exhumed
uh obviously Edward Shu uh vehemently
protested this but it didn't matter they
exhumed to her anyway
so Dr Knapp and they had two other
doctors they kind of laid the body out
in the schoolhouse and gave it a very
thorough examination
now one newspaper from the time reported
on the throat were the marks of fingers
indicating that she had been choking
I don't know if that's a tight with
that's a typo or if that's like the word
with the word
c-h-o-k-e-n like rather than choked
um the neck was dislocated between the
first and second vertebrae uh the
ligaments were torn and ruptured the
windpipe had been crushed at a point in
front of the neck that's with the
newspaper at the time said
so at this point uh they're pretty sure
that Zona did not die accidentally
but because there had been no Witnesses
she was just found at the bottom of the
stairs like in the house and nobody had
been in the house
um you know so they were kind of like
well
the dude like Edward was like acting
really weird since Zona died so maybe we
should check him out
and the thing about it too was that they
thought it was weird because the mom
even before they did the autopsy
she had come forward and said hey I
dreamed that my daughter like that her
neck was broken
um you know so they were like okay well
that's kind of weird so maybe we should
like investigate it although they did
consider the possibility which is
something that you would have to
consider that the mom had killed her and
was trying to like accuse the you know
her son-in-law just to like take the
heat off herself because that would
actually be a pretty clever thing to do
like if you had done it you know I'm not
saying the mom did it I'm not saying
that but um I'm just saying that was
that's a possibility you have to look
into because it could be so I had a
dream that this happened in that
[ __ ] awful lot landish doesn't
it it does yeah it does
the hell was that what the [ __ ] was that
did you guys hear that
it's like a little kid yelling that's
been a little kid yelling I think it was
the neighbor little kid yeah there's a
little girl that lives next door and she
likes she likes to run around in the
yard screaming for some reason yay yeah
I don't know she sounded like she was
right outside the [ __ ] window
but yeah
um okay so at this point uh the
prosecutor pressed
he starts looking into Edward's shoes
past
what he found out was that Edward Shu
had been married twice before
the first marriage ended
um when his wife actually like he got
sent to prison for horse theft and her
and the kid like um the kid they had she
like took off like she divorced them
um and that wife when they interviewed
her said yes Edward she was extremely
violent and had beat her uh while they
were married
now his second marriage
um him and his second wife were only
married for eight months and then his
wife mysteriously died
One Source that I saw because some of
the sources said that they didn't know
like she just mysteriously died somehow
One Source I saw though said that Shu
had claimed to have accidentally dropped
a brick on her head while he was making
repairs on the house roof which
okay I don't know if I'm buying that or
not and I don't know if that's true but
I'm just saying that that's one thing
that I saw like said that that was like
the West Virginia site that had the
story on it
now um in between these two marriages
like he was in prison like I said for
various things theft and whatnot and
apparently he had told another inmate
that he was going to he was planning to
marry seven women in his lifetime I'm
like okay aim high what are you gonna do
like with all those
ladies one of them he killed one of them
he took off well I don't he allegedly
killed he's dead now he can't see me
um so basically they were kind of like
okay well
all this stuff uh you know the previous
wife dying mysteriously and also the
fact that we have testimony that he was
abusive to one of his other wives That's
like enough to kind of get him into
custody right so like and have him like
look into this murder
so what they did was the Mom Mary Jane
heaster she was like the star witness
for the prosecution but the thing about
it was that the prosecutor is like well
I don't want to lean too hard on the
whole ghost story Dream aspect because I
don't think people will believe that so
they tried to stick mostly to just
circumstantial evidence like [ __ ] that
they could prove you know what I mean
like about his past or like other things
that Witnesses had said about him
um but the defense were like oh well
we're absolutely gonna go hard on the
ghost story because they think that
nobody would believe her and it'd make
her look like a crazy person however
this
absolutely blew up in their face because
what they did was they started
questioning her hard like and kept like
going at her about the ghost story and
she was absolutely calm and she just
like kept the story the same she would
not get rattled she just like kept her
[ __ ] together the whole entire time and
said look I had a dream my daughter this
is what she said and this is what she
looked like and she would not waver from
that story like the whole time and so it
made her look a lot more credible to the
jury like she seemed like she was
absolutely certain of what she was
saying also it didn't help that Edward's
shoe
took the stand in his own defense
and he kinda seemed a little bit uh uh
crazy like kind of rambly he would just
kind of come on there being rambly and
like telling the jury look at me look at
me I'm not guilty blah blah so he was
like didn't really do himself any favors
either
um you know the paper at the time said
he made an unfavorable impression I
guess so
so as it turned out the jury only
deliberated for an hour and 10 minutes
and then returned a guilty verdict
now uh because they I guess they just
couldn't wait uh Lynch Mob formed
because they were gonna like drag them
from the jail and hang him because like
I said they just they didn't want to
wait they were just too excited
um but the cops came out and just like
yeah knock it off just go home
so uh so he didn't get hurt in that four
of the mobs organizers did get uh
charged for their part in uh organizing
the whole [ __ ]
now Edward Shu did get sentenced to life
in prison but he only served three years
before he died from the flu epidemic of
1900 nobody in his family came forward
to claim his body
now Mary Jane the mom she lived until
1916 and again never wavered in her
story about the ghost she was absolutely
convinced that her daughter had come to
her like her daughter's Spirit had come
to her in a dream and showed her what
really happened and she was very happy
that Justice had been done
so there was that whole thing but uh
there's the reason why this is so so
famous is because there is in Greenbrier
County West Virginia there is like a
historical marker like a plaque uh
that's commemorating her death
and it says it says on it this is the
only known case in which testimony from
a ghost helped convict a murderer that's
what it says on the thing
but so like I said I can't really think
of
here's the thing like assuming
is this a true story yeah you can prove
that these people existed yeah okay
that's a very like I said it's a very
famous story like in West Virginia all
right
but the thing about it is like
what are the possibilities Here If
ghosts are not real
I mean it could just be that the mom was
just suspicious of the [ __ ] and
didn't really have anything to because
that's what I would do like if I had a
relative for example that was murdered
and I was pretty sure that like their
spouse or something like that had done
it but I didn't have any proof I mean
that especially back then that seemed
like a good way to like get people to
like look into it you know what I'm
saying on the other hand like I said you
do have to kind of get into I'm not
saying that this is what happened but
you do have to kind of look into the
possibility that maybe the mom killed
her
and was trying to like pin it on
somebody else by saying like you know
there was a dream [ __ ] like that so I'm
not saying it's not it's not impossible
that's I don't think that happened but
you know uh Sarah says this one's on
Drunk History it's a pretty good episode
uh but of course Jenny tells it better
well thank you very much thank you very
much I didn't listen to that one there
was one um
I watched somebody's uh breakdown of
this but I can't remember who it was I
think it was Brooke McKenna Brook
McKenna did a breakdown of this case
but I think that's the only one I
watched because I didn't have like a
huge amount of time like to do
um research because usually I like to
watch like a couple things about each
case but I only had time to like watch
one little documentary about each case
but I don't think it was that one though
I don't think it was that one
granther says seven wives is a harem
yeah
Rebecca said hello folks I'm late as
usual this topic sounds fascinating
thank you
grandpa said good friend of mine once
had a harem of hot 17 year olds I was
jealous are you talking about Steve
said Harem seemed like a lot of work
though too much drama that's what I mean
it's like why to me it seems like one of
those ideas that sounds good in theory
well not for me because like I said that
just sounds like a big headache but um
yeah it just sounds like a good idea in
theory but then like when you're
actually dealing with it it's never as
fun as what you imagine Tom you talking
about harems no Steve [ __ ] had it
made best back when we were in high
school
like a drama program wherever that dude
went he'd have a [ __ ] whole [ __ ]
cluster of women
a cluster oh cluster of what's a group
of women called the Gaggle it's not a
gaggle I'm gonna call it a gaggle that's
no fun I thought you'd come up with like
a cool name for it yeah I call that [ __ ]
an encrustation
[Laughter]
a Wobegon of women a Wobegon of women
all right I'm gonna run to the bathroom
all right
so talk about something all right I'll
talk about something like
jump on her
because people do step on now walk down
the hallway one night going to the
bathroom and she was hiding in the
shadows and stepped right on her
she must been asleep
yeah I didn't see her I couldn't see her
man it was dark
yeah no I think uh I think grandparents
is talking about Steve
personal friends of mine went to high
school together
see what's going on here
oh man
not feeling all that good
um
she leaves me in here instead of [ __ ]
doing a commercial okay like I could
fill all this stuff
I know what I'll do I get pokey come
here
yeah
so she runs off
all right
we just sit here and drink Death
she's already coming back
his beard started to get too long
I had to trim it back up again already
it's weird I'm like man this [ __ ]
[ __ ] grows fast
there you are come here Pope come meet
everybody what are you doing why you
backing off from off from trying to take
me over to the scent
she wants to go to the sink so I can
brush her
she's a brush Junkie yeah yeah I keep
making jokes that she used to go to
brushes Anonymous yeah
and that she can stand up her main thing
is to be brushed and she just won't be
brushed on the side of the cheeks with a
hairbrush yeah she like human hair left
on the side yeah yeah she she
commandeered that brush I had to buy
another one
because it's just constantly full of her
hair yeah
a murder of women yeah I mean that's
that's yeah
next Dimension media said another movie
this topic reminds me of is the
changeling with George C Scott yeah kind
of that's a great flick yeah that's
easily one of the best movies of the 70s
one of the best haunted house movies it
is very creepy it is very creepy creepy
with no special effects really
well see that's what I mean a lot of
times it's scarier when you don't see
[ __ ] yeah and also I think it really
helps that George C Scott is in it and
it's like if he's scared of some [ __ ]
then it must be some scary [ __ ] yeah you
know what I'm saying I think I think
that's like a huge part of what makes
that scary honestly the scariest scene
in that for me is like the whole Seance
thing like that weird voice that woman
does and like the tape and everything oh
that's like [ __ ] creepy [ __ ]
creepy all right so you want to talk
about this next case because okay
because what man we finished that first
one like in record time I told you
in record time
so this one is a little bit earlier than
that last one I should have done these
in chronological order I guess it
doesn't matter
what is known as the Red Barn murder and
this took place in Suffolk England
so this was 1827.
and this was a particular murder of a
young woman who again was uh killed by
her not her wasn't her husband because
they weren't married but her lover
boyfriend whatever
and um again it was not her mom this
time but it was actually like her
stepmother
who dreamed about where the body was and
that's how they found out like what
happened
so let's talk about this case so the
victim was a woman named Maria Martin
now she was actually the daughter of a
man named Thomas Martin who is a mole
catcher which I guess was a thing back
then
and this is in polstead in Suffolk
England I didn't like I thought I was
like molecatcher with the I mean
obviously somebody that catches moles
but I guess they needed it a lot back
then because it's like moles had like
[ __ ] up the you know people's Gardens
and crops and everything like that so he
would go and like catch him so okay I
mean it was still kind of like a
that's the thing she was kind of like a
little bit I don't want to say like
lower class but she was like a little
bit more working class because that kind
of like comes into play later on
so in March of 1826 uh she was 24 years
old and she got into a relationship with
a 22 year old man whose name was William
Corder now the thing about Maria Martin
um she was kind of like I said she was
kind of from like a little bit of a like
a lower working class kind of background
but she was like a really pretty and so
like a lot of dudes from like slightly
higher uh you know social strata or
whatever would
um you know would get into relationships
with her and inevitably they would get
her pregnant and then they'd be like
well bye you know I mean like sorry I
can't marry you because you're kind of
like beneath me or whatever it seemed
like she had a lot of that going on so
you know it was kind of shitty
so um so that had happened to her a
couple of times
uh she already had two kids from uh some
of previous relationships which like I
said which nowadays no one would really
give that much thought to it but back
then was like a much bigger deal
you know she was seen as like a fallen
woman or whatever
so she gets into a relationship with
this William quarter dude
now uh actually one of the kids that she
had uh actually belonged to quarter's
older brother Thomas who she had been in
a relationship with previously uh but
that kid died as a baby she did have
another one that was named Thomas Henry
um that was still alive when she hooked
up with quarter now that guy at least he
wouldn't marry her but at least he did
kind of like give her child support and
stuff like that so he wasn't completely
shitty
was actually a local farmer's son and so
he was like from a slightly higher
Social cast but he was also known as
something of a uh
a fraudster I guess he was kind of like
roll into con he was like a con man you
know what I mean and also kind of a man
[ __ ]
there was that too or ladies man if you
want to be nice about it okay just some
you know what I mean well you know hey
what year was this again 1827. okay 18
26 18. long time ago yeah yeah
like one of the first things that he got
in trouble for was selling his dad's
pigs like his dad did not give him
permission to sell the pigs and he's
just like sold them to somebody without
permission
um and his dad was like bro what the
[ __ ] you know what I mean and he kind of
like intervened and like settled
everything without getting the police
involved or anything like that but um
you know quarter was still kind of kind
of a [ __ ] you know what I mean he uh we
did like forgery like he would Forge
checks stuff like that and he was like
he was real into Pig stealing it seemed
like he would steal a bunch of pigs from
their neighbors and why not
now um basically what happened was that
because he was getting in so much
trouble all the time like his dad sent
him off to London like get out of my
face and go get a job or something like
that
um but then what ended up happening was
that he got um called back to polstead
this smaller town because his brother
Thomas had drowned while he was walking
across the frozen pond like he fell in
and drowned and also his other three
brothers and his dad like all died
within like a year and a half of each
other so there was nobody around to like
run the farm but him so he had to come
back and like take the farm over
now so he hooks up with Maria Martin uh
but because she was a lower social
station uh he would absolutely like you
know bone her but he didn't want to be
seen in public with her
however she did get pregnant and gave
birth to their kid uh in
1827. now obviously she was very I mean
she wanted them to get married and like
legitimize her kid
um but this kid also ended up dying
um I saw some sources that said the kid
was murdered or some that just died I
mean it wasn't that unusual for babies
to die back then it was kind of like I
think I saw somewhere that like it was
like 300 out of a thousand births so it
wasn't really that unusual like around
this time period especially like and it
was higher like out in rural areas
so it's not necessarily you don't
necessarily have to posit murder I mean
the kid might have just died because it
died because one of her previous kids
had died too
but uh so even though this kid died
um quarter said oh well I'll still marry
you yeah I don't think that was what he
planned
so now that summer
um while her stepmother whose name was
Ann Martin uh was there like she heard
him say it quarter said
um why don't you meet me at the Red Barn
which was kind of like this you know uh
this place that everybody knew like in
the town and he's like we'll we'll meet
there and then we're gonna go to Ipswich
and we're gonna elope
and he's like basically we need to do it
like right away because I heard that the
parish officers are going to prosecute
you because of all the bastard kids that
you have because apparently that was a
thing that they could do like if you had
illegitimate kids like they could arrest
you which seems crazy but that's that
seems about par for the course I guess
so um so quarters basically like okay
well we're gonna do this immediately
like we'll elope on the Wednesday night
but then he called her to wait and call
her obviously but he like gave her a
message and was like no no now we have
to like put it off until Thursday night
because something came up and then
Thursday night like something else came
up like oh like some like what family
member got sick or something like that
can't do it tonight either so there's
all this kind of he just keeps putting
her off right
so Friday though which was May 18 1827.
um quarter shows up at the Martin's
house like during the day
and he says to Maria we gotta leave like
right now because the Constable is like
coming here he has a warrant and he's
gonna like prosecute you for all these
bastard kids that you're having
um now according to Legal records there
was no warrant but you know so I'm
assuming the dude just lied although
it's possible that he just could have
been mistaken I'm not giving him the
benefit of the doubt on that considering
what happened later but you know what I
mean
so Maria was like well I can't just
leave in the middle of the day but he's
like well why don't you put on men's
clothes like you know a disguise and
then it's like we'll take your regular
clothes like to the barn and you can
change in there and then we'll get the
[ __ ] out of here and we'll go to this
other town and get married so that's
what he said
so after that like quarter left the
house they left separately like he left
and then Maria went out to meet him at
the Red Barn which was only about a half
a mile away from her house this was the
last time that she was seen alive
um so she disappeared quarter also
disappeared
now
a little while later though like he
showed up back in town and he said oh
yeah Maria is in Ipswich where they said
that they were gonna go
um and I married her but I can't bring
her back because my family will be mad
that's what he said
so basically like her family and friends
and everything are like bro like you
know come on bring her back like we need
to know what's going on and [ __ ] like
that
um and so holy [ __ ] she just went inside
the damn covers oh was that what that
noise was
that what that noise was yeah get out of
there Pokey there's nothing in there
[Music]
uh let's see where was I okay yeah she
made that like [ __ ] noise over there
that's like funny
so um yeah so everybody is just like
well you know where is she like bring
her back and uh so he's like uh yeah bye
I'm out so then he like disappeared
again right
so then he starts writing letters to
Maria's family saying yeah we totally
got married oh and we're living we're
very happy now we're living on the Isle
of Wight
and she would write you herself but he
always had like some excuse like oh she
broke her hand or she's sick or we sent
you a letter but it probably got lost in
the mail or something like that like he
always would come up with some kind of
[ __ ] story
so basically everyone starts getting
super suspicious that he did something
to her obviously because that seems
pretty evident at this point
so then Maria's stepmother Anne started
talking about having dreams that Maria
had been murdered and was buried in the
Red Barn so much like the last story
that we talked about this is like
another this is a stepmom not a real mom
but she was just like you know kind of
having dreams about like where the girl
was
so because she what is she doing
now she's coming out oh okay
I don't know what she was doing in there
she was like [ __ ] around comes out of
the door opens it up [ __ ] all happy
I'm out okay what'd you do in there Polk
did you have fun did you have fun did
you have fun in the cabinet yeah yeah
okay it's not Narnia but she keeps
thinking it is
so she keeps having the stream and
finally in April of 1828
she tells her husband please go to the
red barn and like dig around uh and
specifically apparently she said to dig
around in the grain storage bins because
she was convinced that that's where her
stepdaughter was
so he goes there and it's like it's been
a while since she disappeared so you
would think and they said people were in
and out of there you know what I mean so
it seems strange that nobody found
anything like up to this point but maybe
they were used to everything smelling
bad or I don't really know what it was
but her dad goes in there and starts
digging around in the grain storage bins
just like the Stepmom said like from her
dreams and he found his daughter's body
in the green storage bin and it was like
under there was like a sack like a um
like a cloth bag like over it
now obviously she'd been in there for a
really long time so she was really
decomposed but she was still you could
still identify her from her clothes and
like her hair and stuff like that like
that was like still look the same like
she had like a tooth missing so
everybody knew like that that's who it
was they also said that um that a green
handkerchief which they think belonged
to quarter
um was wrapped around her neck
now turns out that quarter wasn't really
all that hard to find uh I guess the
constable in polstead got his old
address from a buddy of his
so basically they found the dude at a
place called Everly Grove house which is
a boarding house for ladies uh which was
in Brentford and he was running the
boarding house with a new wife named
Mary Moore so he just like [ __ ]
picked right up and got a new one I
guess
now this wife he'd actually met through
an ad that he put in the times like you
remember like back in the old days back
in the Victorian era where it was like a
really big thing where they would like
put Lonely Hearts ads like in the paper
and stuff like seeking somebody for
marriage and blah blah that went on for
a long time that went yeah into the 80s
it did yeah but apparently he had um put
a bunch of those kind of ads like in the
paper and he got like a [ __ ] ton of
response I don't know what the ad said
but he apparently it sounded like really
good because he got a [ __ ] ton of
responses like a hundred of them so he
met this woman named Mary Moore and he
ended up marrying her and they were like
running a boarding house now in a
different town
so what they did was one of the
investigators
um he gets into the boarding house by
saying that he wanted his daughter to
live there I'm assuming boarding house
for ladies what does that mean like if
you got pregnant out of wedlock and they
wanted to hide you somewhere that sounds
like that kind of that sounds like that
kind of situation so the investigator
comes in and says uh why I want to board
my daughter here
and then he like walks in on quarter
who's like in The Parlor or whatever he
said he walked in and he said the dude
was like sitting there with four ladies
at breakfast in a dressing gown and had
a watch before like he was boiling eggs
like for breakfast or something and he
was like timing it like on his watch so
he came in and he's like [ __ ]
you're a well he didn't do that like he
pulled the guy to the side and said by
the way
um I'm pretty sure like we're gonna be
arresting you for murder but he said
like quarter said I don't know anything
about Maria I don't know anything about
what happened or blah blah blah
so they searched the whole house they
find a pair of pistols
which the dude had apparently bought on
the same day that Maria disappeared
they also found some letters from a dude
named Mr Gardener which seemed to
contain like a warning about like
somebody had written to him and said hey
they found that girl's body like in the
Red Barn which again seems a little
suspicious
and they also found a passport uh from
the Friendship Bath Center Ambassador
which suggested that perhaps quarter was
about to flee the country
so they arrested him and they took him
back to Suffolk
and they put him on trial so the trial
starts in August of 1828. now this was
like a huge [ __ ] day like it was like
a hugely popular they said man they were
like selling tickets to the trial like
the hotels like started filling up like
way before it started they actually had
to push the trial back like several days
because like people were just like
pouring into town to see it and it was
just like a huge [ __ ] [ __ ] it
was like a circus you know what I mean
there was like crowds in there like you
had to push through the crowds to get
and it was like a big [ __ ] deal
now the thing about it was that they
couldn't because Maria Martin's body was
so uh decomposed they actually couldn't
establish a definitive cause of death
they thought maybe
that a sharp instrument had been like
plunged into her eye socket and they
thought maybe that this had been a short
sword that quarter had which is [ __ ]
up like but that's how you kill somebody
like stick a [ __ ] sword in their
eyeball that's God damn
um but then they thought well that might
not have been necessed because it could
have been when her dad was like digging
around like trying to find the body like
he might have accidentally stuck his the
Spade in there or something like that so
the wound could have come from that
um they also couldn't rule out
strangulation like I said they can't
usually because that's usually kind of
hard to prove especially if the body is
decomposed
um you know and also they found quarters
handkerchief like around her neck which
they thought was a little bit weird also
she had some wounds on her body that
suggested gunshots
so
um obviously she had come to some like
she had been murdered they just didn't
really know how so what they did like in
the indictment they put like a whole
bunch of different like causes of death
in there just to like cover all the
bases you know what I mean basically
they were like
um shooting her with a pistol like
stabbing her with a dagger like they're
strangling her they put like pretty much
everything in there just to like make
sure they got everything
um also they wanted to make sure that um
he wasn't gonna get off with anything
and there wasn't going to be a mistrial
so like other than the murder charges
they also like stacked some other
charges like for some other [ __ ] that he
had done like forgery and stuff like
that just to make sure that he at least
gets in prison time
so Ann Martin the stepmother
she was the one that had supposedly had
the dream
so they basically called on her to give
like evidence of uh what had happened on
the day of The Disappearance and stuff
like that uh the dad came and said about
like digging the digging the body up and
uh basically they had um Maria had a
ten-year-old brother named George and he
said that he had seen quarter uh with a
loaded pistol like before the murder had
taken place and later said he saw him
walking out the barn like with a pickaxe
in his hand
so the whole prosecution story was that
this dude you know he had Knocked Up
Maria and the baby died but she still
wanted to get married and they posited
that
um you know well obviously he didn't
really want to marry her especially now
that the baby was dead so he kept like
stringing her along and then you know he
decided Well it's just easier to like
kill her that was like the way their
story went and also they they suspected
that Maria knew some [ __ ] about all of
the criminal [ __ ] that he was doing like
all the forgeries and because like I
said he was kind of like a con man
and so maybe he thought well it'll be
better if she's dead because she knows
about all of this kind of stuff and
remember how I said like she had a kid
by a previous relationship and that guy
was sending her money they think maybe
that this guy like stole that money too
and that didn't want her to like squeal
on him so there was that as well so he
did have motive like the kids they lived
um one of the kids did like like I said
the baby she had two kids when she met
the guy who allegedly murdered her but
that one of the kids died but the other
baby was okay okay but then she her and
the alleged murderer had a kid and that
kid died yeah how'd that kid die again
um they're not sure okay it's possible
that that kid could have been murdered
too I mean yeah at the same time no no
okay no two different times or something
maybe maybe well yeah that's what it was
before the mama died though not after
before okay and there are some stories
too that like they while they were going
out to the Red Barn so like they buried
the baby like in a field or some [ __ ]
like that so I don't know if the guy if
he killed the baby too it was high
infant mortality back in those days
that's what I'm saying that's what I'm
saying because yeah because I I said I
don't know if this is true or not but I
just like saw I read something that said
around this time period
um in the cities at least it was 300 out
of a thousand infant birds like they
like the kids would die but in the rural
areas it was worse yeah you know I mean
like it was higher infant mortality so
you know and and Mom's died a lot in
childbirth as well because you didn't
have like all the Modern Health Care you
didn't Modern Sanitation you didn't have
any of that kind of stuff and you didn't
have like vaccines you didn't have any
of that kind of stuff so like you'd have
you know dizzy like measles and [ __ ]
like that would kill you you know which
doesn't really happen now a days but it
used to happen a lot back then like
really stuff that's really avoidable
that wouldn't kill you nowadays would
kill you back then so it's possible that
that baby just died you know that it's
that he didn't kill but the thing about
it though is that he if he did kill her
it kind of makes it a little bit more
suspicious that maybe he killed the baby
too because I don't know I don't know
like I said he's dead he can't sue me so
um so what he said
quarter said that when they put him on
the stand he said yeah me and Maria were
in the barn together like that whole
situation yeah we said we were gonna
elope and all that kind of stuff
but he said we got in an argument and I
left
and then while I was leaving I heard a
pistol shot
and then I ran back to the barn and then
she was dead with one of his own pistols
beside her
almost like she killed herself
which
I don't I don't think I buy that I don't
think I buy that well she had other
wounds too not just gunshots
and I don't think the gunshot was in her
head either so I don't know that that
sounds very suspicious to me but you
know what I mean yeah uh so basically
like quarter is saying to the jury like
you know please I you know I didn't do
it it's like you know I just walked away
and then she shot her so I guess that's
what he was implying
um but basically the jury was not buying
it either and it took him only about
half an hour uh and they came back with
a guilty verdict uh so the judge
sentenced him to hang and just as an
added bonus uh that his body would be
dissected afterwards which they did a
lot back then like I thought you were
going to say what I thought you were
gonna say he they sentenced him to be
hanged and then buried alive and then
buried alive I don't know how that works
you very [ __ ] alive after you
hang him but
I mean I thought you're gonna say that
well if you hang them and it didn't kill
them like it didn't break their neck if
it just like and then you took them down
before yeah and then buried them that'd
be [ __ ] cool
would it yeah
[Music]
oh my God yeah but yeah so uh so that's
it [ __ ] thousand house a thousand
corpses they buried them people some of
them were alive and some of them weren't
remember yeah that's right that's the
that's the movie that we're yeah that
we're talking about on Friday we just
did a review of Dr Satan's [ __ ]
minions came up and got him yeah I had
totally forgotten about that part yeah I
was thinking for a second I was like
wait we have zombies now but I guess not
they were just kind of well they're kind
of like I don't know it says like I said
I'm not always I'm overthinking it I'm
sure I'm overthinking it but yeah so so
they didn't only just like say they were
gonna hang him but they're gonna dissect
him too but like I said that was very
common because if you were a murderer
then your body was a fair game and they
would give it to like the medical school
and they'd like study your ass you know
what I mean so basically what ended up
happening so this was all from a from a
dream like I said the Stepmom had a
dream that she was in and apparently
specifically that she was in the grain
bin because that's where the dad found
her like it didn't say that the dad like
dug all over the [ __ ] and then found her
like after but apparently she
specifically said that's where you look
and that's where she had to just do we
had a dream about it because that's what
like the ghost told her I guess
so basically um quarters in prison for
three days and he's like maybe I should
confess to the crime and uh you know so
I can go to heaven or whatever I guess
um now his wife at the time like the
prison chaplain everything said yeah you
should totally confess I mean they're
still gonna hang you obviously but uh
you know you'll be right with the Lord
and all that kind of crap
so um basically he did come out and
confess he did he said that he didn't
stab her
uh because remember how I said they
thought maybe she that he stabbed her in
the eyeball or something but they
weren't really sure he said what
happened was that I accidentally shot
her in the eye after they argued
and uh so it was an accident like he
didn't mean it that's what he said
so they hanged him uh in August of 1828.
they said there was a massive massive
crowd uh 7 000 to 20 000 people came to
watch him because this was like a
massively like popular case like famous
and uh basically said before they put
the hood on him he said I am guilty my
sentence is just I deserve my fate and
may God have mercy on my soul so he did
confess at the end but I'm not really
sure but he said like I said he said it
was an accident
so they let him hang there for an hour
like they did
and then the hangman cut him down I
thought this was very interesting I had
never heard this before so I guess the
hangman when you hang when you cut down
the body like of the murderer you get to
keep his pants and his uh stockings or
trousers sorry like pants's underwear in
Britain I know because then this
happened in England but um yeah this
thing that I saw I don't remember if
this was Wikipedia but it said so the
hangman like cuts down the body and it
said claimed his trousers and stockings
according to his rights what are you
gonna do with that [ __ ] like hey free
pants what the [ __ ] I don't know well
actually as as we will see
a lot of um the clothing and body parts
and stuff like that
because this case was so famous uh you
could make a [ __ ] ton of money with that
stuff because victorians were [ __ ]
crazy man and they would buy anything
especially if it came off a murderer's
body
so uh so the hangman got the trousers
and the stockings and then they took the
body back to the courtroom and then a
whole crowd gathered around while they
slipped the abdomen open like and
everybody got to see it yeah look at it
inside of his belly what's in there yeah
it's [ __ ] funny maybe it's candy like
a pinata what the [ __ ] okay oh what's
the matter she's calling me she's come
over here and brushed me yeah she said
I don't know if you guys can hear her
but she's very very loud she ran up
yelled at me yeah actually she wants to
go out in the living room she wants me
to throw things man I tried to wear her
out like throwing stuff but earlier but
she's throwing out as she catches him
yeah she jumps way up and catches them
yeah and you can you can do that for
like a half hour she'll catch that
I'll get you in a bit hold on we're
gonna be we're gonna be done in a bit
She Gotta Wait She Gotta Wait
I'll get you hold on yeah so they slid
up in the abdomen and everyone was like
ooh you know I mean like they thought
there was gonna be [ __ ] Christmas
presents in there or something like that
because victorians are [ __ ] weird uh
so yeah so they just came in to look at
that stuff then the next day they did
the dissection and the postmortem and
all that uh in front of the Cambridge
University students and the doctors and
stuff oh and there's Pokey she's on the
show yeah she's on the show she's like
[ __ ] down daddy put me down
yeah
also they did some galvanism experiments
so that's nice they hooked them up to
the galvanometer and like [ __ ]
shocked his little arms and legs and
whatnot so they did that that's nice uh
also they were going to take his
skeleton and reassemble it
um they couldn't examine the brain so
the surgeons uh did a they did a
phrenology thing like on his skull
and what they found we should do a whole
show on phrenology because that shit's
fascinating
they found that his skull was uh
profoundly developed in the areas of
secretiveness acquisitiveness like taken
stuff destructiveness
Phil wait a minute what the [ __ ] is that
word philoprogenitiveness what the [ __ ]
does that mean
who [ __ ] knows that's a Victoria word
that yeah and imitativeness yeah which
I'm not entirely sure about that I mean
yeah with little evidence of benevolence
or veneration which fit to it with
exactly what they thought of him well of
course yeah yeah like they knew what he
did so it's just like oh my God we were
right we were right his skull says it
yeah we should do a whole show on
phrenology yeah I love I love the kind
of like crazy Victorian [ __ ] like crazy
Victorian ideas and phrenology is like
hilarious to me so it's like and that
reminded me again because like when I
was reading like researching this case I
was like oh my God we should totally do
a chronology case uh I said like
catching these women for prostitution
and measuring their skulls this is look
the skull all says that they're ours
that's exactly the kind of [ __ ] that
they would do yeah of course they're all
a horse yeah skull says so yeah
[Laughter]
Danny Rowling said uh how did Pookie's
tail get like that again born like that
she was born like that she's a Manx yeah
she's a what they call a Stumpy manx and
that's not I'm not just making that up
that's what they're that's the that's
the legitimate legal term there's three
kinds of banks there's like a um what's
the one called there's one called that
doesn't have any tail that's just like
round then there's a Stumpy manx like
she is which just has she has a little
tail that long and then there's a Manx
that also has like a normal sized tail
yeah which I don't remember what they
call those what's it bless you she's
back there sneezing
uh Pookie should go as a rottweiler for
Halloween I keep asking like what she
wants to be for Halloween but she won't
tell me she wouldn't wear a costume
anyway
so they made a bunch of uh copies of his
death mask and uh they did like they
sold a bunch of his [ __ ] like I said
there was like little pieces of his skin
and like his ear and all that kind of
crap and like they [ __ ] I think they
even like wrote and this was pretty
common too like with murderers they
wrote like an account of the crime and
then they bound it in his skin like that
was another thing they did and they did
it with this guy too
and yeah so for a long time I think like
his bones were um like his skeleton was
on display like at a medical school or
whatever I think it was only
2004. I think they finally like took his
skeleton down and like burned the bones
and like buried him or whatever but for
a long time like his skeleton was on
display now here's something really
interesting because this is really it's
really weird how this weird kind of like
Kismet stuff happens
so about this guy in 1967 there was a
book that came out called the Red Barn
mystery about this whole case
and they that book like drew a
connection between quarter this guy and
Thomas Griffiths Wainwright I was just
talking about Thomas Griffith's
Wainwright because if you watch the
videos on my over on my scare Salon
Channel I was talking about that Boris
Karloff um 1960 series Thriller and they
did an episode on there that was called
the poisoner and it was based on Thomas
Griffith's Wainwright they changed his
name but it was the same guy like all
the details were the same and I was like
that is super [ __ ] weird because just
in one week like hearing that same name
twice in like completely unrelated
circumstances like weirded me out I
don't know like why that happened but
Thomas Griffis Wainwright was a dude
that um
he was kind of like we should probably
do a whole show about him too because
he's actually like really interesting
but um I think a lot of the stuff about
him was exaggerated because like Charles
Dickens and Oscar Wilde and stuff like
that like wrote about him but they had a
whole thing about like how he had this
ring that had like all like poison in it
and he was like poison and everybody and
[ __ ] like that so but they were trying
to like find a link between that guy and
this guy and maybe kind of implying that
he had poisoned I think they kind of
implied that he poisoned that baby like
you said
um you know the baby that died so it's
possible about that but like I said this
case is like pretty famous I didn't even
realize like how famous this was but
they have written there's like a zillion
plays about this there's like a couple
of songs about it they said like back in
the old days when they sell like the wax
cylinders and everything there was like
all kind of like songs so this was a big
hit yeah damn and they said that um yeah
there's like five or six different plays
about it they said that when it was
printed in the paper like they do those
broad sheets like back in they said they
sold like millions and millions of
copies of that [ __ ] you know what I mean
yeah this was like a big [ __ ] deal it
was a big [ __ ] deal and I think too
because it kind of had a little bit of
everything because they were like well
it had like a supposedly innocent young
girl they said interestingly the plays
that they did they would kind of like
play down the fact that she had already
had a couple kids by like a couple
different men like to make her seem like
younger and more innocent and him like a
little bit older like more like a
villain like obviously he's a villain
but I'm just saying they made him like
seem worse you know what I mean and her
seemed like more innocent and so they
did that and um that I don't know it's
just it just seemed like too because it
had the whole paranormal aspect where
they found her body because her
stepmother had a dream of her ghost
coming and saying hey my body's in the
Red Barn like in the grain bin or
whatever and so people were like it
really seemed to like strike a chord and
it was like a massively massively famous
like [ __ ] like during this time period
like there was just everything about it
and it's like like I said songs about it
and everything it's [ __ ] crazy and I
think even as recently as
1980 I think they did like a play about
it as well like on the BBC
so there's that as well
um I'm trying to look and it's like yeah
I think yeah it says Charles Dickens
even published an account of it in his
magazine like all the year round and
there's a bunch of folk songs and
everything like that yeah I think the
last one was no 1990 there was a BBC
Monday play broadcast in 1990 which was
uh about this case and then there was
one in like uh 1991 as well so yeah so
like hugely if I didn't I had never
really heard of it I don't think I'd
ever really heard of this but apparently
it was like a huge huge deal at that
time all right so
you want to talk about like the last
case and then you can talk about
whatever you want because you seem like
you're getting no oh fine I'm just
getting loaded keep my mouth shut let
you go because you're getting it because
you're getting loaded yeah yeah I'm just
trying to let you get let you get
through this material
Shawn Wells says just dropping in right
quick to say you guys rule keep up the
great work thank you very much we
appreciate it we appreciate it
um let's see uh oh macido says Tom you
talked about the case of a walking stick
tapping out tunes on the wall I remember
and then like I looked for it I couldn't
find it
um he says I think I found the video
with it on there it's Arthur C Clarke's
world of strange Powers Poltergeist okay
we should look that up because thank you
because I was looking for it because I
remember you saying about it and I was
like looking to talk about that case but
I couldn't find it that lived um in an
upstairs apartment somewhere in England
and downstairs was a [ __ ] Pub
and the people in the pub knew he was up
there and could do all that kind of
stuff and they'd go up they'd get drunk
and go up there and watch this
Poltergeist perform but somewhere in
England was it the 60s I mean 70s I
don't remember I mean Clark show that
was the 70s right I feel like that show
came out in the 70s so it must have
happened before that I think on the show
it was reenacting well I know that but
I'm just saying it must have happened
before that so it must have been 60s I
think is when it actually happened we'll
have to look that I said man I love that
Arthur C Clarke show back in the day
yeah I might have seen that episode
because I did see a lot of them back in
the day he would lay in bed and he would
put his
cane
and on the back of the [ __ ] headboard
and then it would [ __ ] start tapping
out and his heads could plainly be seen
he wasn't touching it and they could put
it in other places and it would Tap Out
responses if he asked it questions and
stuff and do little dances
evidently they never really got down to
the bottom of it make a little cane yeah
I don't know I'm just making stuff up
um all right so this last case I think
you might know about it because this
case was on Unsolved Mysteries a long
time ago okay but I remember seeing this
so this is the case of Teresita basa and
this happened in 1977.
now this woman was born in 1929 in the
Philippines
and she actually uh graduated from a
university in Manila and then uh
emigrated to the United States because
she wanted to study music
now uh she actually ended up she was
getting a master's degree in music and
would do like she'd give like piano
lessons and stuff like that like to the
kids in the neighborhood and whatever
now she seemed like
um everybody that knew her said she was
like a really Pleasant quiet very
unassuming woman no reason to think she
was involved in anything nefarious or
that she would end up being the victim
of a crime or anything like that
um but yeah that's not how [ __ ] ended up
going
now um she actually did end up uh going
to school like she was in school for
music but then she decided to uh go and
like do some medical [ __ ] so she ended
up like working at a hospital like as a
respiratory therapist
so in 1977 she was living in Chicago and
working at Edgewater hospital as I
mentioned a respiratory therapist and
again uh you know colleagues thought she
was just she's a very normal like quiet
nice person like you know nobody you
would think that anything unusual or
anything like that about
February 21st 1977. uh her friend who I
think was also a co-worker of hers named
rooflobe
she called Teresita and they talked on
the phone for about 30 minutes now uh
Ruth would later say that Teresita was
actually expecting a friend of hers to
come over but she didn't like say who he
was or you know why he was coming over
or what was going on or anything like
that she's like oh yeah well this dude's
coming over whatever and like she didn't
really ask anything she didn't seem
upset or nothing like that
now an hour after Ruth last talked to
Teresita
the fire department got called to
teresita's apartment because neighbors
complained that they smelled smoke
so the firefighters showed up
and they go into teresita's apartment
and they found
um
the place was like on fire
but then when they searched in there
they actually found Teresita naked and
buried under a mattress with a knife
sticking out of her chest like she'd
been murdered and obviously the person
had set the place on fire to try to
cover the crime up but it hadn't been
really successful
even though she was found naked
um so they assumed at first that it was
like you know a sexual assault uh but
they found out later like when they did
the autopsy that she had not been raped
but there was no other
they were having a hard time because
they're like look there's like really no
there was no evidence really left behind
and there was no motive like why anybody
would want to kill her like nothing was
taken like nothing like that it just
seemed like somebody came in the house
[ __ ] took her clothes off and stabbed
her and like [ __ ] then set the place
on fire and they had no idea like why
anybody would do that
um no that's not what it was not what it
was okay that's not what it was
um okay so for the next five months uh
cops had absolutely no leads no like I
said no motive no nothing whatsoever
uh the only thing they found was that
there was like a little piece of a note
like in our apartment that said that she
was expecting theater tickets
from a company or a person uh that she
just identified as a s which they're
assuming were um you know initials
they eventually like shipped her body
back to the Philippines uh where she was
buried
however six months after she was
murdered
there was a guy named Dr Jose Chua Jr
who was a co-worker of hers
and he said you know my wife whose name
and I'm sure I'm pronouncing this wrong
but her name was uh Remy bias they
called her Remy for short
he said that his wife was having visions
about teresita's murder
he said that she would go into a trance
and that teresita's ghost was talking
through her
and one of the things that she said
evidently was Doctor I would like to ask
you for help the man who murdered me is
still at large I am Teresita basa do you
remember saying this on Unsolved
Mysteries I remember seeing this on
Unsolved Mysteries no like this woman
who was just like I don't even think
this woman
wait was the woman A co-worker below her
husband was a co-worker
and like the wife was having like she
was apparently becoming possessed I
don't know I want to say possessed she
wasn't a demon or anything but she was
apparently like having this ghost like
talk to her and said I'm not been you
know I was murdered and I know who did
it
so the doctor was just kind of like what
the [ __ ]
um and the thing about it too is that he
said that every time that his wife would
do that like she'd go into this like
quote-unquote trance and she'd start
talking as though she was this woman
and then like she would wake up later
and not remember anything that she said
like the doctor had to like tell her hey
you said this that and the other thing
and she was always like what you know
what I mean so it was like it was this
really weird situation
um so yeah so apparently like she said
when she was in the trance she said she
told her husband
um you know you don't have anything to
be scared of I'm just you have to help
me solve my murder like basically that's
what she told her
so
um the thing about it so they he goes
and like tells the cops
um it's like they didn't really want to
go to the cops at first like I said you
probably wouldn't because it's like they
didn't want everybody to think we were
crazy or stupid or something like that
because it sounds like really outlandish
but basically what they when the
detectives did come and talk to them
uh the wife Remy she said what ended up
happening she's like I was at work so I
guess she was a co-worker so she was at
work
um and she was in the nurse's lounge and
she was kind of on a break and she
decided to take a nap
she said she woke up from the nap and
saw Teresita standing in front of her
and she said it was broad daylight
um and she just saw her standing there
like she was still alive but like at
this point she knew she was dead
obviously so she was just like holy [ __ ]
but she said she looked like she was a
real person like standing there
um so she like noped the [ __ ] out she
was like nope and she just like left she
didn't like talk to the ghost or nothing
she just like ran out of there
but apparently like the ghost kept after
her
um basically she like the ghost kept
like coming back to her and saying hey
you have to like help me out and all
this other kind of [ __ ] and then like I
said she would go into these trances and
whatnot and would say all these things
but then she would forget
so um so basically like as she kept
going into these trances and saying
about it she came up with a name of who
the murderer was and the name was
because remember how I said earlier they
found that note in there that had the
initials a s on it so I don't think that
I don't know if they told that to the
public or anything like that but she
said that um that she had a name and she
said his name the murderer's name is
Alan showery
who was another co-worker he was also a
respiratory therapist and he had worked
with um worked with the victim
and basically she came forward and said
you know this is what the ghost told me
she said that Alan said that he was
going to come over and fix her broken TV
on that night that they found her dead
but then once he got there he like start
started seeing like all this expensive
jewelry that she had in her apartment
and decided that he was going to take it
now apparently like [ __ ] went sideways
um and they got into argument or
something like that like obviously and
so he basically just took it and then
killed her
and then set the house on fire
so he wasn't and he took her clothes off
to make it look like somebody had just
broken in like to rape her so he wanted
it to look like an attempted rape but
mostly it was just kind of like he got
in a fight with her because he wanted
her [ __ ] and she wouldn't give it to him
okay give it to him and so like he
killed her that's apparently well that's
what the ghost said but they you know
that's what they found out later on
so basically the cops were like okay
well this sounds like a crazy story but
you know what could it hurt we don't
have any other leads right so they
decide they're gonna go and like
question this guy
now so they found out that this guy Alan
he lived really close by Teresita and
when they asked him he said yeah I was
going to go over and fix her TV that
night which is crazy because that's what
the ghost said
but then they talked to his girlfriend
whose name is Yanka and she said he
doesn't know how to fix a [ __ ] TV so
like why the [ __ ] would he say that
um and also another thing that the ghost
said was
um if you go to the house like he'll
have like the girlfriend his girlfriend
will have my jewelry
and so when they went to the house the
girlfriend did have the jewelry that um
that he had given to her and said hey I
bought you this honey even though he'd
stolen it from her and like murdered the
lady
so that was apparently one of the things
that the ghost said was that the
girlfriend will have the jewelry that he
said that he that he bought for her
so basically like as they questioned him
about it he like caved in and he said
yeah I did it
um he said what I was gonna do he's like
I went there at first and I was gonna
Rob her I needed money for rent and I
didn't have any so I was gonna Rob her
but then things got out of hand clearly
um and he murdered her so he stabbed her
in the chest and like took her clothes
off to make it look like like an
attempted rape and then set the house on
fire like to cover up the crime but
obviously the house didn't burn down
like because the firefighters came
before that
um but then like he realized that she
only had thirty dollars in the house and
uh so that's when he decided he was
going to take all the jewelry
um he's like I didn't rape her or
anything like that it was basically just
like a robbery and then he was
that like I said just escalated into
something horribly worse
so he so since he confessed like the
cops arrested him
but at first he actually pleaded not
guilty
now he was uh in jail for four weeks
um but then after that he changed his
plea to guilty
so they're not sure because there were
two different stories about why he might
have changed his plea one of the stories
goes that because uh teresita's ghost
had allegedly like spoken to this other
lady
then they're like well maybe her ghost
like showed up in his jail cell as well
and scared him into like taking [ __ ]
responsibility for the [ __ ] so there
could be that
or uh probably the more likely scenario
was that his lawyer said well if you
plead guilty you might get a lesser
sentence like they might go easier on
you uh like I said that's probably more
likely but I think people likes to think
that maybe like the ghost was coming
back for revenge and like came into his
[ __ ] cell and like told him to like
cough it up and everything like that
um so basically uh yeah so he pleaded
guilty now he only got 14 years which
you know seems not very much like for
the brutality the crime and he actually
only ended up serving five of those
years which is even crazier
he got let out on parole in 1983.
and actually like moved to New York City
last I heard I don't I don't know like
what he's doing nowadays or if he he's
even still alive but I don't know how he
landed up serving like five [ __ ]
years though like he did get 14 years
but then they let him out after five on
parole and as far as I know
I don't know if he ever like committed
any crimes after that or anything like
that but to me
I don't know this one it seems like kind
of harder like it's you know
this wasn't as long ago obviously like
as the other ones because I kind of feel
like there was maybe some uh
rational explanations for the older ones
like you know maybe it's been so long
like details got changed maybe you know
that and in those cases they already had
suspicions toward a certain person like
before any of the ghost [ __ ] happened
this one is like really really weird
because they had no idea
who killed this woman apparently they
had no leads no nothing and nobody
suspected her co-worker as far as I know
like at any point
so I don't know like I said I don't
really believe in Supernatural kind of
stuff like this
but
I'm trying to think of like another way
that this could have just been like well
when you say Supernatural you're
thinking of the uh of something that
was called Supernatural a long time ago
I mean in the Roman era
electricity electricity would have been
considered to be Supernatural yeah the
radio definitely was almost damn near
considered Supernatural in the 1900s
I mean they were trying to talk to dead
people with radio yeah
they were they weren't quite sure why
radio worked
right now
uh there's a really good theory that's
happening from top-notch dudes sir Roger
pembrose and Stuart hammeroff and have
been listening to them develop their
Theory
for years now probably close to 10 years
and they're making a lot of progress on
it
it's called Quantum consciousness
and they're basically proving pretty
much that Consciousness is not
computation all right
you're never really going to make a
conscious computer or super computer
it'll mimic Consciousness maybe
superficially but that that computer
will never have a feeling of what's
called koalia it will never that
computer will never be conscious and
feel like it's there
it will not have the sensation of being
there
it won't experience things like beauty
or experience things like understanding
it will just operate it'll compute
when you're dealing with a human mind
and animal Minds you're not dealing with
computers
they all including animals and pretty
low animals
experience koalia they have a feeling of
being
feeling of existing in a place and
experiencing things
and here's the weird thing that is a
Quantum effect that's happening inside
neurons
each neuron has thousands and thousands
of these little microtubules
stretched out through that neuron
that seemed to be made of a meta
material that allows photons
to flow down there through that tubule
and it seems to be super involves super
conductivity
that's a big deal that means that a
neuron is not just a a switch an on off
switch like say
in a binary based computer
this is an analog system
each in in each one of those
neurons
it's basically you're basically what
you're dealing with is a quantum
computer
which they're trying to work on making
quantum computers also
quantum computers are going to be
[ __ ] fantastic a quantum computer
might be able to experience quality or
Consciousness but not a not a digital
one
well here's a weird thing
that both
pembrose and hamroth are saying and you
can hear them talk about this on YouTube
just look up Sir Roger primrose
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] can't you hear I'm
talking the damn phone it's [ __ ] just
look up Quantum consciousness
with Roger pambrose and Stewart Hammer
Penrose pambrose and hammeroff Penrose
Penrose goddamn p-e-n-r-o okay she got
it correct well I don't want people
looking it up and spelling Iran Stuart
hammeroff look for him he's an
anesthesiologist he was just trying to
figure out what makes you conscious why
is it that anesthesia blocks out your
consciousness
uh and what mechanism by what mechanism
does that happen
and uh
they can explain it in [ __ ] detail
everything they're saying lines up with
the Poltergeist
ESP
precognition
Spirits ghosts they are not saying that
but they say if you believe in those
things this is an explanation
and I've seen it so and I know that's
what they're talking about
well here's a weird thing
once you're dealing with
Quantum forces happening inside the
brain now you're dealing with what's
called superposition and entanglement
and once you have that that brain
physically doesn't have to be there that
person could die
and all those photons and all those
[ __ ] Quantum particles would still be
interacting and it would just continue
on
possibly into other dimensions
which would be like having an
out-of-body experiences
which I've had
so go check that out eventually they'll
figure all this out so it's not
Supernatural it's just extremely high
tech we don't know what Consciousness is
so it may be plausible that a person
dies their Consciousness lives on
all right and communicates back
to get this done but it's a rare event
go or it would be happening all the time
okay that's what I'm saying it's like it
seems like if that was yeah
you know if it was something that could
be done like a lot that it would happen
a lot but yeah even when I was like
doing research for this show like this
it's all their emergency there's really
not I mean these three cases are kind of
like the best known ones
and it doesn't and like I said this
third case
it seems weird to me I guess like maybe
not now that I'm saying it out loud but
it seems weird to me that somebody that
didn't really know her that well in life
at least as far as I could determine was
the one that was getting the Visions but
maybe I mean from what you're saying
yeah maybe if her Consciousness maybe
that maybe this woman was the only woman
that was like receptive to it because
I'm thinking haven't haven't had an Obe
and an nde myself
based on those experiences I would say
the average person if they got killed
and died wouldn't give a [ __ ] that it
happened they would just move on yeah
like whatever it's not that important
all right from your point of view at
that time you got other [ __ ] to do
there's Cosmic consciousnesses involved
and
singularities happening inside the
universe and
uh it's just you you're like yeah yeah
that happened but yeah [ __ ] it you know
what I mean that's not a big deal kind
of like respawning in a video game like
that dude so you'd have to have somebody
that [ __ ] would have like a very
intense drive maybe children involved
that survived to go back and try to find
somebody that they could communicate
with to give that information
so I'm not saying it's impossible I'm
just I'm saying it's plausible but it'd
be rare it'll be a rare occurrence and
another thing is it'd be very rare that
it would ever be reported like you might
have might happen but the person that
can get the message is like well I'm not
going to the cops with that
you know what I mean well yeah a lot of
that in this situation they didn't
really want to go to the comps like when
the [ __ ] first started happening because
you have to think that the woman that
was supposedly getting the messages
um was a nurse or like worked at a
hospital and her husband was a doctor so
they were kind of like well we don't
want to look like morons that believe in
like crazy [ __ ] like in front of the
cops but like after a while because the
woman kept having like trances and [ __ ]
like that so finally they did go it's
like hey maybe check this out like we
know you guys don't have any other leads
and the cops were just kind of like well
whatever what the hell I mean they did
find out that the guy that was accused
like lived nearby and like worked with
her and stuff so they said okay well
we'll investigate that but Hammer off in
the newest video that came out hamroth
says that
based on their findings
it's not just
animals
that are experiencing koalia or a
feeling of being
he says that even inanimate objects have
us have it
but it's just nowhere near as good or as
strong as a
as an animal or a living creature they
have it but magnitude
orders of magnitude greater in other
words kind of what he says is
the universe itself has kind of a
Consciousness as a whole
if you had or picked up a rock
it has the Consciousness but it has the
consciousness of a rock which isn't much
that's kind of what he said because it
says there's something about he says it
has to do with the collapse of waveform
that the collapse of waveform happens
almost which I don't I gotta go back and
listen to it again it has something to
do with how subatomic particles are
interacting with one another which is
the essence of the feelings of kawalia
but they happen to be happening
they happen to be happening happening
inside microtubules inside of a brain
which gives a a lot better coherence to
it but he says that that's also
happening in inanimate objects it's just
that the consciousness of say a rock
isn't much
you know it can't know much it
experiences only being a rock
which I kind of had it like what's that
but
I guess it's all just on a uh on a
spectrum
maybe I've always sensed that and maybe
that's why I always kind of like man
like I knock over an inanimate object
and I'm like sorry yeah maybe I'm
because I'm always done yeah and I felt
like a dork for doing that but maybe I
was on to something yeah you know listen
to the brand new stuff they're talking
in front of some big university and both
of them go up and they they both explain
it
Roger gives it on a very uh using using
quantum theory and then hammeroff comes
in he kind of humanizes it being a
biologist he and and an anesthesiologist
he explains what this means to you
you know and what and he says different
things depending on the audience
in front of a bunch uh
academics it's very it's kind of dry
in front of
regular people he's like
yeah if you believe in paranormal stuff
this is an explanation for it
okay yeah you would have to have this
for that stuff to be true but he says
we're not saying this stuff is true
because we haven't really looked at that
we're just saying these things you're
hearing if they are true it's because of
this it's because of that it's you're
right which like I said that's something
a scientist would say because it's like
well we don't know because we can't
prove it so it's like you know
definitively so we're not going to say
that I've seen it I've seen it what
hamrod's talking about and I was like
thank you Mr hammeroff yes now you
[ __ ] made me feel a lot better
Jenny's seen it
it's just not as good as when I was
young
you know remotes flying and [ __ ] [ __ ]
being torn down but it's not now I'll
admit I didn't see the shipping down
like I was I was at work she saw the
aftermath yeah I was at work she saw the
remote but I did see the remote and all
that yeah and weird effects that
happened and I did see that door open
and that's what we're talking about yeah
and it's because of uh Altered States Of
Consciousness can affect
matter
like Mind Over Matter
but it's not through will it's just uh
the subconscious mind does it somehow by
the those Quantum effects they're
talking about which kind of leads to
would kind of say like reality isn't as
real as we think it is matter isn't
solid that kind of stuff matters mostly
just a cloud of atomic of of particles
and subatomic particles there's not much
there and somehow the mind can alter it
under certain circumstances
yeah I mean I don't know like
like I said
I kind of feel like this last case in
particular
um is kind of more relevant with what
you're talking about there yeah because
the first two cases like I said the
other explanation that might be there
might be other explanations because like
I said it was a long time ago and they
already had suspicions yeah for as to
who it might be but like the third one I
remember seeing this on Unsolved
Mysteries I don't remember what episode
it was on but I remember seeing this
because it like stuck in my mind hamroth
comes straight out and says once a
Consciousness is formed it really no
longer need it really no longer needs
the physical brain around it because
the quantum processes that are happening
inside that brain
are entangled with one another and
they're in [ __ ] Quantum superposition
so you could actually take the physical
structure of the brain away and those
particles would still be in that same
interaction although he did say it would
be a little bit different that uh it
wouldn't be as organized but the parts
of it would still be there it would have
a sense of koalia in other words it
would have a sense of being
weird but no that lines up with what I
saw
when I went Obe I had a sense of koalia
like I was there but I was a lot simpler
than I was when you're inside a brain
you know you're like less organized
what I call it they're like a happy
squirrel
and there is information but it's
external
if you wanted to know something you're
kind of accessing it from like an
external Cosmic records
like you can know anything you want to
know but you have to want to know it and
then you're infused with a sense of the
knowing and you understand it but then
when your mind changes to something else
you kind of forget it you go on to
something else so you're not retaining
things very well
but you don't need to because survival
is very different there you're not
you're not eating to live you know
you're not an animal
you're just a Consciousness flowing
through
kind of like a metaverse really
Jacqueline Russell said do you think
that's what DMT Taps into when people
yeah okay yeah hammeroff says the same
things he says LSD and DMT and mind
expansion drugs seem to kind of enhance
the uh these Quantum effects that are
happening inside the brain and he says
and then he said other drugs that are
anesthesia's do the opposite that they
shut all that down
so there's two different spectrums there
see that's why I was always kind of like
fascinated by LSD and stuff like that
because I
and as much as I enjoyed my experience
on it I would like to like do it again
and like experiment with it in other
ways because
once you get beyond the physical
Sensations and everything like that you
kind of want to go inward yeah I was
trying to go inward I had to kind of
babysit her because she's wow this is
cool yeah yeah chill out
I'm gonna go outside roll around no
don't roll around well I mean I was well
but like you said I mean yeah because
it's overwhelming you're like look at
this yeah well and the thing about well
the weird thing about it is that it
didn't seem I don't overwhelming isn't a
word that I would use
um but it did make because it didn't
really
it didn't really show me anything like
super like crazy no but it did make
everything look
cool yeah like everything just look like
not that different but just like cool
like you saw the regular world but it
was like beautiful yeah you know what I
mean in separate way yeah you looked at
it like in a slightly different way so
you kind of wanted to experience yeah
it's like oh I want to like touch the
wall because the texture felt really
neat or you wanted to like go look at
like um you know like a TV screen
because they had like pretty colors on
it so it was like that kind of stuff it
wasn't anything like really really like
out there or overt I didn't see anything
like crazy Distortion or nothing like
that but it's just like everything
looked tightened and I liked that so I
kind of wanted to like explore it a
little bit but when I I tried to kind of
because you said
you know because it so it lasts a while
yeah and you were kind of like well you
know lay down and go in Inward and like
I did that for a little bit but I was
like this is kind of boring I just kind
of like wanted to run around and do
other [ __ ] you know what I mean yeah I
wanted to like do like external [ __ ]
like I wanted to like listen to music
and like touch the wall and [ __ ] like
that yeah you know what I'm saying yeah
I wanted to go like inward but I kind of
had to keep an eye on her because I you
know I didn't really trust her yet on it
well yeah because I'd never done it
before it takes a couple times before
you can because once a person knows what
to expect and we're not saying do this
okay we're just talking about yeah we're
not working we're not yet we're not
we're not we're not advocating it and
I'm not a doctor
it takes a couple times for you to get
real comfortable with with it so you
know what to expect once you know what
to expect you can kind of you can you
can
you can monitor your own behavior yeah
yeah that's see I mean I still like for
safety's sake I wouldn't because I man I
hear some stories about it's like yeah
we dropped acid and like [ __ ] drove
around I would never do that but yeah we
used to drive on it see I don't think I
would ever trust me I don't even I don't
even like to drive like sober you know
what I mean at all so it's like I
definitely wouldn't if I was like uh you
know on something no me me and Steve
used to drive on it in high school you
can drive well
you just have to uh
want to drive well because you're not
really intoxicated not in the way it
would be yeah that's the weird thing
about it that's the weird thing about it
I was having a hard time though because
I was trying to you know because I have
a friend who wanted to try it so I told
her that I would like kind of give her
an update while I was doing it and so I
was trying to type on my laptop like to
tell like to message her like what was
going on and I was having a hard time
doing that because the laptop kept going
like that it was getting smaller and
like and I couldn't really see all that
good yeah so finally I just called her
because I was like [ __ ] it I can't you
know what I mean like I couldn't like I
felt like my fingers were too long and
like the the screen was too narrow and
it's like I was like this isn't working
okay so I just called her then like
talked her through it the ideal way to
do it is get get comfortable with that
and then go into sensory deprivation
where you don't see or hear anything you
just lay down
and you try to just go inward that's
that's how you that's the best way and
then you'll see things
see you'll have ideas and sometimes see
the future or the past
it's but it all depends on what what it
is what it was exactly you took and how
much
see that's the kind of thing that
interests me because like I said because
I'm a you know I'm a creative person and
it's like so I kind of wanted to
explore that like maybe would help my
writing or maybe you know like that kind
of stuff that's kind of why I was
interested it does that that's why
that's why the Cure was so good yeah and
the Rolling Stones
yeah so I'd have to like do it more time
yeah because that's why I want to show
them things you're like man why am I
being shown this and then you understand
it's because you're it's almost kind of
like [ __ ] you know your subconscious
is able to come through and show you
things that you knew but you didn't want
to admit to yourself or things that were
you were being shielded from knowledge
that you weren't that you knew secretly
but didn't want to face so all kinds of
weird things you could the Indians call
it Spirit walk you're in the spirit
world yeah they were doing that see like
I said that's a very interesting concept
to me yeah there's any Indians knew
about it other kind of other kind of
drugs like ones that you know
um other kind of drugs are not as
interesting to me yeah yeah psychedelics
yeah I mean but those are have always
been very interesting to me because and
it's not really those aren't really
recreational in terms of you know hippie
[ __ ] I mean they did that but
they're kind of full of [ __ ]
um it's to me it's almost like Priestly
activity it's holy
and if you don't approach it that way
you're going to get inferior results
you have to approach it as if you were
going through something [ __ ] holy
that you're gonna that you're going into
the spirit world
yeah I think that is a good way to like
yeah to go into it like it's like a
special like ritualistic yeah well
people that I've known that have done it
they said well we only like do it like
once a year or something and it's like
we kind of like you guys expect it yeah
I feel like if you do it all the time it
might kind of like lose its luster or
whatever yeah because I really did I
mean it's been a while since we've done
it but
I had a very very positive experience I
felt like crap the next day and not
saying that but it wears you out it does
wear you out like yeah I was just I
wasn't I didn't feel like terrible like
a hangover but I felt like really really
tired like really really tired and
really sore yeah your brain [ __ ]
sells or your synapses are just firing
[ __ ] like crazy yeah your your your
unconscious in your subconscious and
your consciousness of all kind of just
Blended more into a bigger [ __ ] Mass
you know
there's subconscious material in your
consciousness
it was the first time that I had ever
um
I said I I know this is funny but I
remember thinking this I was like you
know all those like obnoxious like
people that are like hippies that are
like into Grateful Dead and all that
kind of stuff and how they're always
like oh everything's okay man and [ __ ]
like that like I remember very clearly
like thinking that while I was I was
like oh I get it now yeah yeah like I I
get it I get it like when they say like
oh we're all one man it's like you want
to punch him but like when I was on it I
was kind of like it oh okay I I get with
it yeah that's a very superficial I got
it that's like a superficial very bass
line that's like the entryway into that
altered state you go yeah we're all
connected what you're talking about
isn't Star Wars
is the force you know yeah force and
your connection with the force and that
there's a dark side to the force and
then there's all kind which is it's
basically Buddhism you know modify
Buddhism but the Germans talked about it
too
so you kind of come in on a basic level
but then you say okay that's the basics
but what about this and what about this
subject and then it starts to
get more
specialized instead of generalized so
you can actually look and then during
that sometimes you can't control it new
ideas come in that are more important
you hadn't thought of
like don't worry about that what about
this oh yeah yeah I didn't know about
that but you just have to be there some
of it you can retain and some of it you
can't remember
like for me I kind of wish
if you record it I would have to like
record it yeah I mean if like if I was
gonna do it again or if I was like doing
that as like an experiment I would have
to like record myself talking or
something like that so then like later
on I'd be able although I remember
pretty much everything
from that time like it's not like it's
not like drinking where you like black
out like some periods and forget [ __ ]
you said it's not like that at all like
I have a pretty clear memory of
everything that happened even though I
was like altered yeah you're not
intoxicated no it's not the same it's
like really weird and it's like hard to
explain to somebody that hasn't done it
yeah your your uh reflexes and your uh
mental or your physical facilities are
just as good as I could definitely ride
my motorcycle on that no problem
probably ride really good
if I wanted to [ __ ] test myself in
speed I could probably ride real fast
now would I get could I get killed yeah
you could get killed but you could do
that you could get killed [ __ ] well
you could get killed sober even if you
were sober but you might push yourself
harder on that
um so I wouldn't recommend it I'm just
saying that no you could probably ride
real well
but you could also wipe out riding real
well when you understand motorcycle
especially if there's cars on the
[ __ ] Street you know what I mean cars
are the main problem yeah that's what I
mean I kind of feel like people say oh
I'm a good driver so I'll never get in a
wreck I'm like there's cars there's
there's other there's a lot of factors
that you're not in control of I mean
like [ __ ] can happen somebody could
throw a [ __ ] concrete block off an
overpass and kill you you don't know
right so you don't you don't have
control over a lot of things in general
I recommend stay at home
don't go out on that at least until well
not what is four really not really I
don't I don't feel like I mean I
wouldn't I mean I've only done it once
but
I wouldn't trust myself to go out and
even after I'd done it a few times I
don't think I still don't think I would
no Native Americans got it right they
were messing with with uh hallucinogens
for [ __ ] thousands of years it's a
holy thing that this is this is a
religious ceremony
it's you go into a trance to solve the
tribe's problems
to see visions
see solutions for the problems yes or
your own problems right it's like that
yeah Jeff yard said I would use
psychedelics for serious self-reflection
but I want to share the experience with
someone I trust always heard that you
should never look in a mirror yeah I
heard that as well although I did and I
didn't see anything weird I didn't I
didn't look look for a long time or
anything like that but I just I looked
pretty normal to me oh my goodness we
keep you awake yeah guys let's keep me
wait man
we'll even go from two and a half hours
you want to knock it off yeah and Alba
makes something to eat what you gonna
make
uh we ate up all the damn
homemade tortillas I got flour tortillas
you want a bean burrito or something no
you know what about uh okay so what do
you want I don't know what do you I
don't know I'll figure something out I
don't think I have any meat dog other
than that hamburger
I got taco meat that's it
you wanna want a beef burrito beef and
bean Maybe
oh I don't know
um I feel like we've eaten a lot of
tacos last I know but I gotta finish up
okay I'll figure something out do you
want to order pizza
the money oh okay I was gonna say I
think I have a coupon for free oh okay
yeah okay but I don't know like I don't
know how much I gotta order like okay to
do that we've been spending so much on
[ __ ] I know we gotta go out we gotta
go Saturday too yeah
for a Halloween party but you know what
I mean yeah all right so oh I forgot to
say that like um
I know I put it in the comments but on
our Night Flyer review like it cuts off
at the end and that's because our power
went out yeah they shut the power off
for the whole uh neighborhood well yeah
they're upgrading the Grid or something
like that around here they sent us an
email like a week before about the you
know the power outage but I forgot yeah
they're building two huge
[ __ ]
complexes up the road here so they're
giving us a stronger power grid to
handle all these new houses that they're
building yeah because they're building
houses all kinds of houses but that's
why that's why like the power went out
yeah and then it came back on like 10
minutes later and I was like well maybe
we should like get back on but then it
went off again yeah so I was like okay
we're probably a good thing
so it was off for a little while but it
came back on like later on but I didn't
want anybody like frequently freaking
out because yeah I forgot to mention it
but uh so yeah so we'll be back uh
Friday night for the Side Tracks show
and I'm not going to do the costume
Friday night okay but I'll do it Monday
I'll do it for the Monday show because
Monday is actual Halloween
I gotta try I gotta try it out Saturday
though and see how it turns out I got
everything except one thing but the one
thing isn't all that isn't all that
important like I can do without that but
I got everything else
um but yeah so hopefully you guys
enjoyed the show this evening I had a
good time did you have a good time yeah
okay that's good
all right so we'll be back uh Friday
night for the Sidetrack show maybe we'll
get some moonshine
now that I know they have it right down
the street I'll have to go down there
and get it they don't have the butter
pecan but that's okay
um but yeah so we'll see you guys again
Friday night thanks everybody for
dropping by thanks for super chats and
we'll see you guys again on Friday good
night